foreign
[Music]
hello ladies and gentlemen this is Tim
Ferriss and this is yet another edition
of the random Show episode number
4732 Kevin Rose we've done a series of
entrepreneur
amazing
good fella
generous soul
Avid wear of trucker hats yes and
Drinker of red wine as we've already
established by the sound effects that
preceded this introduction Kevin nice to
see you yeah it's good to see you as
well
we need to do this in person more often
we do we do it's so fun it was so fun to
do in person
I know so what are you what nectar of
the gods are you suckling over there I'm
having a little bit of the mascot from
Napa Valley
the Harlan family we know will obviously
over there and they are quality
producers of quite fine Cabernet red
wine that is just amazing this is like
my favorite
it's I'm I'm to be fair I'm conflicted a
little bit because I am on The Advisory
board but
I they make great wine they do make
great wine it's fantastic one I've been
over Yonder back when I was living in
NorCal you and I had quite a bit of that
even before you were on the board
yeah very very tasty grapes tasty tasty
grapes absolutely they can put that on
the label if they want as a quote tasty
grapes from them in the back founder of
[ __ ] punch face grease exactly I'm sure
that'll do wonders for their price of
their wines yeah for that very high and
top shelf yeah
Legacy multi-generational branding that
they're going after I think that would
really help that's what you want it's
just tasty grapes tasty grapes I am
drinking I don't know if you've ever
seen this before this thing which I'm
drinking it's this little can of
r13 Ginger mule hard ketones so this is
ethanol-free alcohol hold on I have
other
ethanol you're drinking hard ketones now
that's
pause
don't knock it until you've tried it
so r13 butane dial I know you're gonna I
know where you're gonna take that so the
r13 butane dial a few things number one
is you do get drunk on this stuff you
cannot drive if you drink this stuff
like all alcohol pretty much like all
alcohol but the point being that it is
not ethanol so you are avoiding some of
the metabolites and issues through liver
metabolism that you run into with
regular alcohol it is also an appetite
suppressant so if you're used to
drinking and then just housing five
pizzas like I did the other night
then this is a counterbalance it speeds
you up though it's ketones right so it's
like it's like well here's the thing
it's no it's ketones but it's not beta
hydroxybutyrate or a performance
enhancing Ketone this is a hard Ketone
intoxicants so you have to be very
careful they have warnings no pregnant
ladies
Etc all this stuff do not consume more
than three per day you legitimately you
legitimately get
intoxicated when you drink this you have
to be very careful but it contains burn
when you pee no it does not burn with
when you pee it does not give you
horns or a vestigial tail or or eyelid
hair none of those things
and I've been enjoying experimenting
with this because what I will sometimes
do and I haven't done this much but I
will have one of these
you're an investor I can look at your
sipping I am not an investment yeah this
is like the Wayne's World you're like
you're like drinking Pepsi and I will
have one of these every night at 7 pm I
am I am not I'm not an investor I have
no vested interest unlike that Shield
Kevin Rose
I have no passwords
[Laughter]
that you called it tasty tasty Graves
creams yes so yeah I am not I'm not
involved I have no problem Hawking the
stuff when I am but this is actually
very tasty so Ginger mule tastes like a
Moscow Mule but it has no ethanol based
alcohol in it and here's what I'm going
to do so I'm going to have this first
hopefully and this is I think perhaps
wishful thinking but I'm hoping the
ketones will have some neuroprotective
effects that when I then shift into
fifth gear to have this
which is a tequila I've become very very
fond of I'm not involved but I have been
drinking it because I had it first at a
restaurant called suerte so suerte here
in Austin which has excellent Tex-Mex
food very high-end outstanding Cuisine
and the first time I had this that the
server recommended
was at that restaurant when I was having
dinner with Chase Jarvis and we were
both Blown Away
Chase is a great guy Chase and his wife
both both wonderful humans and we were
both really impressed with this and I
enjoyed it so much that I ended up
buying a bottle which is quite rare for
me because I don't drink that much but I
do really like tequila I mean if you're
in Texas and you drink alcohol you owe
it to yourself to explore the range of
tequila and this stuff is outstanding
it's just fantastic so okay this will be
this will be step two I have two
questions for you actually one question
you can cut this later if you want oh
you said you you said on a private text
to me that you had a couple drinks with
the Tia last night
Tia is not a big drinker no at all every
time I've gone out to dinner with him he
has one tequila I had more than he had I
had more than Peter okay was the end of
this Ketone thing as well was he you
know was that what you were drinking or
no no okay we were drinking red wine
from Spain which was fantastic in the
moment I've just found I love red wine
I'll continue to have it on occasion
maybe I'm just becoming the Crypt Keeper
if anybody gets the reference got to be
pretty old already to get the reference
my body
tolerates wine of any type increasingly
poorly with respect to sleep if I have
three glasses man I feel like
somebody put a pillowcase over my head
and just punched me in the face for like
an hour in the middle of the night it's
rough do you do you get the the hot
sweats I do reliably and you can track
it if you have an aura ring or something
else on you look at it you're like good
Lord what happened to my body yeah all
the night this happened to Daria too
she's like a sweaty linebacker in the
middle of the night like it's like you
don't want to hear it it's like it's
brutal a lot and I know that's gonna
happen which is why if I'm gonna have a
drink a real drink or otherwise I have
not found this stuff to help sleep by
the way the the r13 as much as I am
interested and I have been I have boxes
of this stuff and I'm not an investor
because I'm interested in how I might
use this to moderate ethanol based
alcohol consumption which I enjoy but
let's just say I can pre-game with one
of these get to a point where I'm kind
of loopy I will say that one of the
these compared to one say tequila soda
the r13 will [ __ ] up my verbal
Acuity or my ability to speak much more
than that's all you're really looking
for
so it's perfect for this part of the day
you just want to be slurring your words
yeah yeah and and this stuff also per
can I have found to throw off your
physical coordination a lot more than an
equivalent single alcohol drink so you
do need to be careful with it it's not
it's not something you want to pound and
then grab a chainsaw and go out
Gathering wood well that's the weird
thing is it's it's such a non-obvious
like I would never have imagined you
were going to say that when you started
this podcast because typically I think
ketones is like okay I'm gonna chug a
bottle pre-workout
so I mean I guess you could go lifting
right now drunk lifting if you wanted to
no this would be terrible for
performance this is bad for performance
I mean it's not it's well let's let's
put a different way it is not a
performance enhancer in the same way
that other ketone
supplements might be so I have taken
even earlier today I took a different
exogenous Ketone supplement because I
was eating pretty low calorie today
before recording a podcast this morning
and it within 20 minutes or 25 minutes
reliably kicked up my
my blood Ketone levels as would be
measured with say pee on a strip or oh
no the Precision actually one yeah you
can use you can use a breathalyzer you
can use the fingerpricks I didn't
measure it but reliably I will see a
bump of one to two millimolars which is
substantial and I went from being foggy
and tired and slow to being fast with my
words
not having to search for turns of phrase
everything was coming quickly it was
very reliable as a performance and
answer this what I'm drinking will have
the opposite effect
[Music]
actually this is really interesting one
question for you on that front end
because like I know you know having
traveled with you a ton
to countries where you've been so
generous as to be our translator
where Tim will translate for you for
about six hours and then you'll just
shut down and then I get so grumpy I'm
gonna get pissed he's like you figured
out translating Google translate's good
enough God damn it I don't want to do
this job anymore exactly Tim was like
our paid translator of one of my
birthday parties for like the entire
trip unpaid unpaid so so I'm curious
though you know you mentioned how quick
you know it puts you on your words just
flow like butter like is it would it
help in a situation like that do you
think have you tried it ketones when
translating for translating I'm sure it
would help if you're using the right
class of Ketone because when we're
talking about ketones you have Ketone
Esters you have Ketone salts and I'm not
qualified to talk about the intricate
science of it all someone like Dr
Dominic de Agostino who I've had on the
podcast at least twice
is one of the preeminent
researchers in the space who also works
with I want to say the Department of
Defense might be DARPA in synthesizing
compounds for special forces and Native
cells seals using it at some point right
and so they they need measurable benefit
and one of the measurable benefits
is that it helps you to sustain
physical and cognitive performance
under conditions of low oxygen
[Music]
which you might experience if you're
doing say extended deep diving or
submersion which you might also
experience if you're at altitude so I
recently this would have been
early October I used ketones to help
acclimate to altitude and then tapered
off of the ketones so I wouldn't
perhaps prevent some of the
physiological adaptations that I would
want to sustain without using ketones
every day so they're they're fascinating
I will say if I'm taking the other side
of the argument and making a counter
case
I am skeptical that taking exogenous
ketones constantly when you are
consuming a normal diet which is
relatively rich in carbohydrates so your
blood glucose is not necessarily
pathologically elevated but if you're if
your glucose is normally elevated and
then you have very elevated blood Ketone
levels
my understanding is that does not
readily occur
in nature at least with humans in an
organic capacity unless you are in a in
a dangerous position as a diabetic where
you're experiencing
ketoacidosis which is very can be fatal
I mean it's very very precarious so my
feeling is if this doesn't occur in
nature because normally you'd be
producing ketones in a state of
starvation even though I should be clear
we're producing ketones a lot of the
time but in Trivial amounts by the time
we get to the point where we're noticing
it and we're breaking down meaningful
body fat in order to produce these
these alternate sources of energy which
the heart and the Brain really love the
heart and the Brain really like ketones
you may prefer them over carbohydrates
is that is that right
I've heard that said I I don't have that
much difficulty believing it from a
first person perspective when I've done
extended fasts especially
the the ketones provoked or the
maybe it's just the spectrum of changes
provoked by fasting say on day two or
three where my ketones will naturally be
in the 1.5 to 2.5 millimolar range
that that condition feels different and
I feel sharper than I do when I use
exogenous ketones supplemental ketones
to get to the same measurement using a
single device
and I'm not sure why that is but it
feels different you feel much sharper
when you get there through fasting in my
experience yeah and that is to say not
all ketones are created equal so this
right here is going to make you slur
your words and [ __ ] the bed for a
performance perspective but might be fun
as an experimental ethanol replacement
and then there are others
there are many different options out
there that are documented for performing
excuse me documented there go the words
documented for improving performance
so one question for you Tim and we can
move on to all the whole slew of topics
that we have otherwise this will be a
two-hour Ketone episode but I'm curious
when when people are listening it's like
there's no doubt right now A lot of
people are like okay this sounds crazy
this sounds kind of fun maybe I want to
try this you've already mentioned the
drink yep what about if you're just
doing it for mental performance like is
there the one brand that I know had
licensed the patents from somewhere in
England was hvm hvmn
I do I believe that they are very
focused on this particular type of
Ketone the r13 I don't want to say that
with great conviction but I would say to
everyone you owe it to yourself because
you're putting something in your body
that is going to have one way or the
other
could have a significant impact on your
blood chemistry and your entire
biological system
read a few studies find out what the
exact Ketone is
and go on PubMed or somewhere else and
just read at least a few abstracts yeah
but we just want to know what you're
taking dude just tell us the brand what
do you what do you choosing up with in
the morning what am I juicing up with
like what did you take before the
podcast I'll grab it I'll grab it hold
on a second I'll grab it okay okay I'll
Entertain You on why Tim is is gone
so what Tim doesn't know is we've
secretly replaced his ketones with
diabetic horse urine I love it
so so this right here you know what the
details are not
the specifics are not on the back of
this it's on the back of a larger box
but the label the label does not scream
scientific credibility but it's a fun
label so this right here it's going to
be a little hard to see the the label
reads Ketone Aid so that is the brand
snake water Ketone Ester and
electrolytes
so it's keto Nester plus electrolytes
the brand name is Ketone Aid one word
snake water I want to be super clear
though because I think people can [ __ ]
themselves up with these things I am not
a doctor I do not play one on the random
show or on the Internet do your reading
and talk to your doctor because there
are people for which something like this
would be contraindicated so pay
attention yes I mean never never take a
supplement from the man that created
[ __ ] punch just that's as fair to say I
think that I think those are very wise
words
yeah yeah furthermore you know just as a
side note I want to say I I love when
I'm talking to someone
and maybe especially in Austin like you
can't throw a rock without hitting
someone who wants to without hitting
someone who wants to tell you about
their latest like Ayahuasca experience
it's just like you can't escape it and
if you're at a group dinner sometimes
that if something will come up related
to psychedelics you just you cannot
avoid it in Austin which
rubs me the wrong way sometimes but I'm
kind of I guess I contributed to it
probably in some way so there you go
just desserts but the point I want to
make is be having a group dinner and
somebody will say
I don't really don't do drugs I just
drink and I'm like
Oh you mean the civilization Destroyer
that's the only one that you use right
it's like
it's yeah I mean to pretend like alcohol
is it's just yeah totally yeah come on
anything you put in your body that
provokes a change that's a drug banana
ketone
tequila
you know first prescription medication
they're all they're all drugs every time
I talk to Tia about alcohol or anyone on
his team they're just like don't do it
why it's just so it's the worst it's so
bad for you and yet sometimes you just
want to have a drink sometimes you just
want to have a drink speaking of which
let's move into the show let's move into
the show so New Year's resolutions what
yes what do you what do you have Kevin
and is there anything that's been on
there for like five years straight and
you're bringing it back
we have at least five years of random
shows that we could we could probably do
a flashback to every single failed one
all the failed wrestlers [ __ ] amazing
Montage oh my God there'd be so many
[Applause]
so I would say I want to hear yours as
well I'll do a rapid fire on on mine and
and if you feel like digging in deeper
on any of them you're welcome to so I
mean the no-brainer is just not drinking
in January that's that's a no-brainer
it's just a good reset have you done
that before
yeah
we kind of like that that was a little
so so hand signal we got no I mean it's
like you know it it depends on how many
months or how many
oh boy it depends on how you define
January so the witness is getting
uncomfortable he's sweating starting to
shift around listen I just got back from
a seven day silent Meditation Retreat I
did not do any alcohol
Paragon of self-control you didn't get
hammered on your meditation yeah exactly
so so question for you if you're not
going to drink I know this people may
not know this
flying makes you super super nervous as
far as I remember yeah I don't like
flying
we shouldn't be in the sky yes so it
doesn't make sense yes so when Kevin
flies kevkev tends to have a drink or
two or three I mean I like a glass of
champagne on you know it's like you know
there's nothing wrong with we can
pretend that's that's what we're looking
at but no you're right so here's the
deal I'll give you so would you have to
cut back on your travel for a booze for
January no no like I'm not that bad
anymore like I so like when I flew back
from the meditation I didn't drink which
is great did you take a handful of Xanax
though tell me the truth yeah exactly no
I didn't I was fine I was totally fine
wow look at that go meditation it's one
of those things where
I don't know why it is you know what it
is about flying it's this is gonna sound
ridiculous it's a I'm not flying the
plane like I want to be in control I
kind of want to fly it but I don't know
how so that doesn't make sense either so
it's just it's a very confusing thing
and it's something that is just you know
we all got our things I've got plenty of
things actually this is a good one yeah
I haven't unpacked this with you ever oh
boy you're you're Tim Tim the The
Fearless like you do all kinds of crazy
[ __ ] like what's the one thing that
people wouldn't know that scares you
terrified of heights terrified of
heights are you serious yeah and so when
I go rock climbing I do this as a way to
try to inoculate myself against some of
the fear
to the extent that if if I get to a
height that many people even up in a
tree like 15 feet something like that
My legs will start to shake I have I'm
very afraid of heights and when I rock
climb
I'll be blaming somebody let's just say
and it's my turn to go before I am even
on the wall I have sweat pouring off my
hands so so I need to so I end up using
can't just use chalk because it turns
into this
sticky mud on my hands yeah and if I go
up a wall even if it's a small wall it's
it's a 50-foot wall
I'll have to reapply chalk like five
times so what I will do it's actually
people might find this useful there's a
product called Rhino it probably has
another word there but Rhino basically
antiperspirant for your hands used by
some competitive rock climbers
and that is the only thing it was
recommended to be by a professional
level climber
that has helped and
I am
fairly sure sorry company it's a great
product I if you're
constantly inhibiting perspiration
through the hands I have to imagine
there may be side effects I would think
so I I haven't used it all the time but
if I'm training let's just say
as I would like to this will come back
to the resolutions I guess but we'll
train at least twice a week three times
a week like for a period of time
why not right if I did that three four
weeks on one week off and did that for a
quarter I don't it'd be hard for me to
imagine that would do a lot of damage
but I am very afraid of heights to
answer your question have you ever done
the VR thing where you walk out on the
plank and it's like you're up at a like
15 story building or 20 story building I
have I'm actually for whatever reason
fine with that maybe it's because it's
not convincing enough yet or the
kinesthetic feedback isn't quite there
yet
or the depth perception
is quite not there yet
from an Adaptive eye tracking
perspective
would you ever bungee jump
I have bungee jump before and it scared
the [ __ ] out of me and I wanted to do it
in part because it was going to scare
the [ __ ] out of me and I did it off a
bridge in Taiwan this is forever ago and
everyone was was going backwards
and
they were kind of falling butt first and
I was like all right I wanna I wanna get
tied up and I want to jump off head
first
looking straight down as I'm going
and I did it and it scared the [ __ ] out
of me
but
I will say despite all of this exposure
right so if this were I guess it's what
prolonged exposure PE therapy it does
not seem to have reduced my fear of
heights at all
whatsoever
and it's crazy I had no idea that was
that's it for me oh yeah that's a real
thing
just just talking about it I kid you not
the more I'm just talking about Heights
right now and my hands are sweating
laughs
so I've done a lot of you know this like
I've I've done a lot of rock climbing
and and did it a bunch in my youth and
and I I think that the sweating thing
would happen to me as well but not to
the point but that's just natural like
you're just like you're pulling up a
wall especially if you're lead climbing
and you're clipping in as you're going
yeah it's much scarier but I didn't know
they made antiperspirant for your hands
though yeah they do and I'll I'll look
it up and keep keep going on your yeah
all right so so January booze free booze
free means no booze that's right no
drinks
okay wine is fine but everything else is
out what why what kind of just kidding
oh my God amazing moving on so the sad
thing is I've been wearing so I have a
whoop on an Apple Watch on and I've I've
tested all these devices and I really do
enjoy playing with them and trying all
the latest software out and one of the
things that is really disappointing to
me is in the last year actually a couple
years now since covid
in in watching Apple watch will have a
cardio Fitness level built inside of it
and mine's like been slowly going down
and I'm like oh [ __ ] you know like sucks
I gotta I gotta get back into shape so
you know my dad died of a heart attack
my Grandpa died of a heart attack like
cardiovascular issues are are not new to
my family so for me this is a kind of a
big deal you know so yeah I'm really
focused on cardiovascular fitness for
this new year and I I essentially a
couple things just let people know where
I'm at I've tried out all the different
latest versions of software for Fitness
tracking I I'd like to link this up in
your in your show notes there's a
scientist on YouTube called the
Quantified scientist that I really like
he's awesome he does basically uses a
lot of the kind of gold standard ways to
track
sleep and he'll hook himself up to all
the real professional devices and then
also use the the consumer devices and
say how good are these devices like how
accurate they are they really predicting
the levels of sleep how good are they at
heart rate detection while jogging like
is the ore any good because it's moving
around on your finger all the time
there's all these like open questions
and all he does I think it's his
full-time job now is just put out new
videos with all the latest fitness
trackers and tell you if they're any
good and a lot of them are crap that's a
cool Niche though yeah it's a really
cool Niche he's like all right we're
gonna look at you know hydrostatic
underwater weighing for body composition
and compare it to whatever this thing is
you're wearing like if that if we take
it as
I think I'm getting that description
right but if we if we take this
underwater approach as these Olympic
gold standard how do these things stack
up right that's cool exactly exactly
yeah it's really cool and so his the
tldr is that the Apple watch is actually
pretty damn good now it didn't always
used to be but it's really good for
heart rate
and it's really good for Sleep the whoop
I like because it's it's not as good as
the Apple watch but what it does is it
does activity specific tracking so for
example and yes you can do that on the
Apple watch too you can say I'm doing
elliptical or I'm doing all this stuff
right but the whoop is cool because you
can say okay I'm gonna sit down I'm
gonna do a meditation it'll detect that
you're doing that and then it'll give
you your heart rate in real time or I'll
show you the graph after you're done
over over that like that activity and
it's much harder to try and find that
data Apple apples
their device is amazing their software
kind of sucks like health kit in the
Whole Health interface it's just it's
not a consumer app it's very clinical
feeling so the data is there but it's
not represented in the right way if that
makes sense so anyway long story short
Aura has a brand new sleep algorithm the
the Sleep the Quantified scientists have
yet test that out against all these
other things their sleep algorithm I
think was pretty screwed up before but
they're testing a new one now you can
enable it in beta so I'm going to wait
and see how that goes for for sleep
tracking but anyway
my methods for cardio Peloton rower I'm
not involved in Peloton in any way don't
have any stock but I I saw their new
rower and it looks pretty interesting so
they give you a 30 day money back
guarantee I just bought it it'll show up
in the next couple of days I think
that's good it's they say rowing is 80
of your muscles which is amazing all at
the same time so if you're looking for a
quick hit like 15 20 minute workout I
don't know I'm I'm excited about it I'm
gonna give it a shot oh I can hop in for
a second so I had a chance to to test
the Peloton roller for the first time
and this is part of due diligence
because
I have been having conversations with
Peloton and you didn't know this before
putting together the prep for this this
conversation yes a Peloton
and I have been talking about possibly
doing something in terms of sponsorship
on the podcast related to the rower and
as is my first step with all these
things
I asked to use a unit I said I have to
test it and I had the chance to test a
unit this would have been
I don't know two or three weeks ago and
I was very impressed with it and
I can give you a couple of tips that
might help other people who are also
getting the unit so the first is
the form correction is very helpful and
almost everyone will use their arms too
much lean back too far and
use their legs incorrectly so I don't
know what the form correction is is this
like in the software or something like
it is in the software so it will show a
profile of you on the rower
and it will flash red in areas where you
need to correct form how does it know
that
the front camera sensors in the seat and
sensors on the pulling mechanism and
there are probably other sensors on top
of that
and the feedback is actually quite
helpful there is a competitive or former
competitive I think he's still current
competitive rower very large white guy
who has excellent form and there are
other instructors who have excellent
form but he is the instructor who I know
and I'm blanking on his name people can
figure it out who has a competitive
background and the reason that's
attractive to me is if you are going to
be a competitive rower in the long term
and succeed
no injuries if your Technique is not
efficient
you are going to suffer from repetitive
use injuries 100 and they will
debilitate you so I like the idea of
modeling at least in the beginning
stages the technique on someone who has
competitive experience so that would be
a recommendation I apologize I'm blank
on his name the last thing I would say
and I've provided feedback product
feedback so we'll see since I think they
could make modifications quite easily
with firmware instead of changing the
hardware and if my experience with the
Peloton bike is any indication they will
make constant firmware improvements so I
expect by the time I'm even saying this
that once you get your shipped unit I'm
hoping there may be some modifications
of it the sensors at the very back of
the seat are very sensitive
so
my experience was you may get
a bit too much feedback in terms of a
red alert indicating you're leaning back
when you may not in fact be leaning back
that far so two suggestions and these
are my experiential suggestions not any
type of I don't think official
suggestion scoot your butt forward just
a little bit so that it's not all the
way at the back of the seat second is
absolutely focus on not leaning back
excessively and so I do think as a
practice especially for engaging your
legs it's good to almost Lean Forward
slightly as you do the exercise
and what blew my mind is once I had the
technique feedback
once I had
the guidance in terms of exertion and
some metrics to watch
I found that I could do longer rowing
workouts I could actually do a long
drawing workouts and I have a concept 2
rower and I like the concept two rower
but what I found is without any of those
feedback mechanisms
I would crank up the resistance because
there's a resistance dial on the on the
concept too crank up the resistance and
I would go
balls to the wall for 500 meters and I
would effectively be done my heart rate
would be through the roof my arms would
be sore but my legs would not be sore
and I was roasted I could go longer
right but if if I were trying to do
something let's just say as a short
morning workout
500 to 7 I'm sorry 500 to 750 meters and
I was like okay I think that at this
point my biceps are the weak Link in the
chain using the Peloton rower
and following the feedback easily could
do a 30 to 45 minute workout which
better engaged all of the musculature
that you were aiming to engage so I had
a very positive experience very positive
experience I'm sure that they will of
course and they already I'm sure have
many plans to iterate on the firmware so
I think you'll enjoy it I'll be curious
to hear your thoughts now I will say
since you gave a peek behind the scenes
earlier I'll do the same favor
when you send me those naked
mirror selfie shots post-workout every
once in a while I'll get one of these no
which I always do yeah I'll get one of
these from send me Apple cash right
after no it's grapes it's great yeah
yeah I do I I did upgrade to premium on
your only fans
and I always get the tricep shot and you
you have good triceps I always get the
tricep shot look at that there you go
still there still got it it's not
frequent it's not frequent that I get
the quad or the calf flex I don't get
those I have good quads now what come on
well they're getting better I've been
doing a lot of squats also I'll send you
some updated pics all right great great
good good good good fantastic yeah I was
I was just going to ensure that you
understand that using a rower involves
your legs I just wanted to make sure
that those no you know what's funny is
it no all jokes aside Tim like seriously
in the last like four weeks I've really
focused on my legs and I'm enjoying it a
lot no [ __ ] good it's like I don't know
about so I've always I still hate abs
like there's no there's nothing about
ABS that I'm ever gonna love but like
once you actually start to build up your
legs there's like this I mean it's like
with anything Fitness related like
there's this painful first few weeks and
if you can cross that Chasm and kind of
get on the other side of it yeah I don't
know things are looking up on the legs
and also you just feel you feel a lot
better you feel a lot stronger you feel
much more stable when you're doing that
kind of work and I don't want to
interrupt your flow on the do your stuff
but I am
I have some physical
resolutions as well why not we can jump
back to mine let's just keep it going
popcorn it around as they call it yeah
so I am going to be spending most of
January and February focusing on skiing
I find skiing to be
A Perfect Blend of some of my favorite
things and I have done snowboarding I
just tend to injure myself immediately
because snowboarding comes very
naturally
I still think I'm a 15 year old
skateboarder and I start doing stuff at
the park and getting fancy and then I
injure myself inevitably so rather than
try to rely on restraint which is not my
strong suit I just don't allow myself to
snowboard anymore
skiing
is a wonderful combination of
time in nature being outside
moving with speed under control where
you get an adrenaline hit
but ideally without excessive Danger
it is subtle and
you can refine technique for a long time
and not run out of room to improve
you can make Quantum leaps in your
performance with proper instruction and
you could do it like when you're 72 like
people and you can do it when you're
older and that has become so much more
important for me and
to this end though I am or both in
process and leading up to it so let's
just say I have actually not that much
time I have like 10 days so I'm not
going to do a whole lot of conditioning
in the next 10 days but I have done a
sum leading up to it focusing on lower
body lower leg I've torn as you know
I've had so many injuries so I've torn
most of the connective tissue the
meaningful connective tissue in my
ankles over the years just from the
outrageous decisions and and bad
commitments with Combat Sports and
getting heel hooked and things like this
so I as a as a result need to compensate
by strengthening
the lower legs
on this on the lateral portion the rear
of my calf everything to try to
compensate for weak ankles and terrible
dorsiflexion
is that your weak point if someone want
to take you out it's just go with your
ankles
you gotta you gotta go for the ankles it
is the it it is a weak spot so yeah you
can go for the ankles if someone wants
to come at me
go for the ankles and I'll just pull out
my concealed carry and shoot you in the
face anyway if you're pissed at that
[ __ ] punch floor price just go for his
ankle yeah yeah if you go for the angles
just just just be prepared I may be
packing so there's that
and the reason I bring all this up
though is that it's one thing for me to
make commitment in say an urban
environment to improve lower body
strength and to work on stability and to
do so in a way that is sort of clinical
in a workout without Real World
engagement
but if I really want to Stack the deck
in my favor to accomplish that
I want to set the environment and I want
to set my social interactions in such a
way that that goal is served and I
recognize this is a very fortunate
position that I'm in but I do think
people can
borrow this
maybe framework or way of looking at
goals to think about all right I say I
want to do X
how can I optimize spending time with
people who will help me achieve X or who
are already achieving X or are trying to
achieve X how can I put myself in
locations where I am more likely to
interact with those people and absorb
some of these maybe ancillary habits
related to my primary goal through sheer
exposure so Tim tells tell us that that
is I think that is such a very very
important thing this idea that the sum
of your closest friends largely makes up
you know what you're into your hobbies
like the things you get excited about
like when you find
there's something new you want to go
after let's call it skiing or something
like
you you're lucky because you can you can
pick up the phone in like world-class
skiers will answer and say let me take
you out for the day you know see your
Tim Ferriss but like how do you how do
you recommend that people going into the
new year if there's something new they
want to get into like or they they look
around at their friend group and they're
just like this doesn't help me get to
the next level like what do you do if
you're stuck like that
go make some new friends and I would say
furthermore let's let's
Professor so aside from Friendster I
will say and I'll I'll mention this I
don't mention it that much the the four
hour Chef confusingly is actually a book
about accelerated learning in skill
acquisition I talk a lot about this in
the four hour shift so even if you buy
it you don't give a [ __ ] about cooking
and you just want to learn about Metal
learning and acquiring physical skills
there's a section called meta learning
in the four-hour chef and I highly
recommend that people dig into it
because the recommendations work and
I've used them dozens of times now one
of the points that I make is if you go
on Google and search whatever your
Target Sport is let's just for the time
being assuming I want to play this
pickle sport pickleball yeah I haven't
tried that yet yeah pickleball's fun
pickleball is fun it's not the I mean
it's it's more ankle friendly than
tennis but you can still you can still
roll an ankle or two if you're not
careful so it is exciting Austin is also
not only the the Third Coast Capital of
Ayahuasca and unending Ayahuasca
conversations but also pickleball
there's a lot of pickleball here
and in sort of Central Valley California
it's become very popular but putting
pickleball aside for a second because
that is not yet an Olympic sport let's
say you want to get better at a sport
that is
a professional sport or I should say
amateur or professional sport
represented in the Olympics
could be swimming could be skiing could
be
just about anything
snowboarding Etc
if you search for
snowboard
silver medalist bronze medalist or even
maybe gold medalist from two Olympics
ago
there's a very good chance
and this is not to minimize their
achievement but the fact of the matter
is there are many sports that are
financially rewarded in the US
basketball baseball and there are many
that are not and I don't think that's
fair in a sense it's not reflective of
the dedication or skill necessary to be
good at certain things gymnastics would
be another one
however that does mean an opportunity
for a lot of people and you could find a
silver medalist or or a bronze medalist
who by the way in many cases is just a
gold medalist who had a bad day that's
it
and you could get one-on-one
remote or in-person training with them
in many cases for a hundred bucks an
hour
that's amazing I hadn't even thought
about that yeah it doesn't even matter
any metal is fine like bronze no no no
and copper was the thing whatever it
like yeah you don't need you don't need
also if you are I mean I am not the best
skier but I do I do ski Lifetime and
I've done some hella skiing and I've
done a lot of off off-piste kind of off
terrain I'm not a great skier but I have
a basic Foundation of ability
I do not need a gold medalist I need
someone who is substantially better than
I am and this is very key and who can
teach
right because in many cases you will
find say a college coach maybe they're
retired doesn't really matter in a given
sport who will be a far better
instructor and get you further ahead
than a gold medalist if that gold
medalist is never really taught
everything they've done since age five
has become second nature so they can't
explicitly name or describe what they're
doing
so you have a broad menu of people you
can choose from if you're trying to
learn a new skill and it is so
mind bendingly affordable in so many
cases there's so many fields let's take
an example
I am very excited about archery so some
of my goals relate to archery for the
new year and I've been taking it
seriously for a while I feel very
comfortable with compound I'm focusing
now on recurve and barebow are you
better than a Tia or is Tia Bern you
this is into it as well I don't know
we've I have no idea I mean a TIA a TIA
has gone so
uh with archery he's you know making his
own materials putting on his own
Fletching he said he's better than you
full than he might be I'm just kidding
then he might be
I am I feel very confident in my ability
to do what I've tasked myself with doing
well you got into bareback writing a
long time ago that actually remember
that you were doing bareback archery in
Japan I was it's not bareback but I was
doing yabusame horseback archery in
Japan with traditional bows that are
long bows about six feet long was there
a saddle on that horse or no there's a
saddle but the saddle is very very thin
wood the only purpose of the saddle is
to hold the stirrups on the horse so you
can ride the horse without
sitting on the horse so you're
effectively doing a wide squat in the
stirrups the only purpose of the saddle
is to hold you on the horse
and the saddle is not intended to be sat
upon I have two antique saddles at home
I know that I that were my reward those
were my first real reward I gave myself
in any meaningful way for anything I did
and it was for
the for our body hitting number one New
York Times that's why I have the Saddles
yeah so gosh Tim it's we've known each
other a long time man a long time I
remember walking in
yeah what was that downstairs place you
had where you had you like walking you
went down this hallway to Tim's house
and it was like there was a big huge
Japanese like you had the full armor
right yep
what was that it was a little condo you
had or something that was so the armor
had traveled with me for quite a while
this was Kendo armor that I used in
Japan a condo you had in San Francisco
right with a little yeah it was on the
it was on the right hand side so as you
walked in
it was in two different places one place
is one place I rented and then another
place that I bought and the place that I
bought which was in Glen Park I guess
both of them were in Glen Park
if the first one had this hallway
leading in pretty long hallway and it
was all kettlebells it was all
kettlebells that's right it was just
like 20 cowbells yeah and then you walk
up and the armor was to the right it was
directly to the right of that cross this
walkway that went from the living room
into the kitchen and the armor was
directly on the right when you came in
to the place that I bought later you'd
walk in and on the left hand side was an
entire chalkboard wall that had artwork
on it so it's like 12 feet of chalk art
which is incredible so good I was so
impressed with this artist and then on
the right hand side I had the Japanese
armor and that was the Kendo armor I
used when I was in Japan Tim's house
back then was exactly because I met you
and you just launched for our work week
it wasn't it was just the launch party
was when I met you for that and I
remember I came to your house and I
remember just walking at some point to
hang out I didn't know you that well and
it's just like you walked on this aisle
of kettlebells it was like the Hall of
kettlebells
and then there's like Japanese armor and
like weird Saddles and [ __ ] maybe the
Saddles were later I think Saddles were
a few years later yeah yeah and then
there was like books all over the place
with all these little note things in
them and I'm just like this guy is crazy
but like
uh the the early the early the honeymoon
phase of our friendship that's right
kettlebell date so I am I suppose taking
a long roundabout way of saying
do not assume that you do not have
access to really good
teachers
it's it's right there it but people
don't look for it because they assume
that it's not
and this type of Outreach and finding
instructors I did well before I ever had
the first book right and you can do it
they're they're very direct ways to do
it yes particularly if you know the
right questions to ask you need to know
the right questions to ask it is your
job to use the instructor like the
Niche expert Google you want them to be
to provide feedback you have to know how
to be proactive as a student
and if you learn how to do that you also
remove one of the requirements I gave
and that is you can take someone who is
not experienced in teaching
and make them a good teacher by virtue
of feeding in the right questions and I
I don't want to sound like I'm hitting
it too hard because frankly I I make
next to nothing on these books
but the four-hour Chef meta learning
section has all of this it's very
in-depth so I encourage people to check
it out very cool
yeah should we get into a couple more
resolutions or yeah let's do it
I'm I've I've I've I've shifted into
fifth gear and I'm I'm making the
transition to the Lala just FY just FYI
I'm on my second and a half class so
it's gonna get interesting real quick
here all right so a few more things on
my list and then we can move on to I
want to talk to you about your nft
Ventures and figure out how that's going
but
so I think I finished my seven day very
first ever
Zen Meditation Retreat it was fantastic
in so many ways and I would say that the
one thing that it gave me is when you
sit for eight hours of meditation per
day
you realize very quickly that 25 minutes
is actually nothing it's it's just
nothing and and
it has really really helped me create
since returning from that trip I had
just haven't missed a day and it's just
been solid so because it feels like it's
so trivial it's like of course I can
find 25 minutes to go yeah and sit or do
a double sit in a day
and get to 50 or 55 if you're doing
walking
along with it but it just reframed that
entire thing for me which I think is
fantastic and it also gave me this sense
of just knowing I want to go deeper in
this realm and and it
the experience of the community and at
the zendo and everyone getting together
you've been on one of these
and I know yours was a little bit Rocky
be curious to see if you'd go if you'd
go back to one but I had a fantastic
time in so I know meditation is going to
be
top priority out of all the things that
I do going into next year
well I guess let me ask some follow-ups
I will say that I I would be open to
doing something like that again I would
probably try a different format so at
the time I'd done a vipassana silent
retreat
and this the sitting was similarly
intensive in the vast majority of your
day is sitting or walking meditation
mostly sitting
and I've I've I've told that story
before so I won't tell it here if people
want to hear that and you know
effectively
it's it gets into some very heavy stuff
so I I won't rehash it here but if you
want to hear the story I told it on 10
happier the podcast with Dan Harris and
we got into it quite a bit I had
effectively a full
psychotic unraveling at my extended
Meditation Retreat which relates to a
bunch of childhood trauma and abuse and
so on so it's it's
not what I would consider family
listening but if people want background
they can listen to that it ended up
being a very important experience for me
but it also scared the [ __ ] out of me
and I was very worried about being in a
psychological free fall and thank God
Jack cornfield who has been on this
podcast a number of times
who is who is a an extremely masterful
and skilled
teacher
meditator
who is clinical psychologist has worked
with
veterans adolescents who cut he has a an
extremely hybridized toolkit which makes
him very very very effective and he
walks the walk that guy is as legit as
it comes so people may also want to
listen to the podcast I've done with him
I would be open to testing another
format though and I've been extremely
impressed with Henry shookman
who is who is your Jedi Master as I
understand it Henry's amazing he's been
on your podcast twice now I highly
recommend people go back and listen to
those he has and I want to thank you for
that introduction you had recommended it
and he's outstanding he is a very very
good teacher he's a compelling speaker
and
I could see delving into a different
format to see what that provides
and I'm not in a rush to do it I am
however feeling some
urgency to begin meditating again I've
completely fallen off the horse and so
that has been at the very top of my list
and I continue to find excuses to put it
off and it's funny because this happens
to me
once every year or two where I'll be
meditating meditating meditating and
then
suddenly it's like the it's like the
excuse Factory took a vacation for a
year and then it's like I'm back
and all of a sudden I fall off the horse
and I stop and it does not take a lot
for me to feel tremendous benefits I
would say
if I do and my default for kickstarting
this tends to be a concentration
practice like Transcendental Meditation
I just find it to be the easiest way to
get back on the horse yeah Mantra based
is easy like that it's good it's good
yeah using something like that or if I
want to make it an even easier on-ramp
using say the introduction or the
introductory course with the waking up
app and Sam Harris I find that to be
extremely well done it provides you with
very discreet and and
cumulative tools as you go through it
really anything to get you into the
habit and I'll actually bring up
something from a conversation I just had
this week with James clear so James
Clear wrote a book called Atomic habits
10 million plus copies
habits are his thing and he shared
something with me a phrasing that I
found very powerful and very memorable
and I'm going to paraphrase here I'd
want to speak for him but he effectively
said something along the lines of
when in doubt keep the schedule reduce
the scope
which means let's say you've made a
commitment to work out
one hour every Monday
in the gym you're going to do leg day
every Monday
and maybe it's not a 60-minute
commitment it's just I will do my leg
workout every Monday
and your leg workout as it's currently
outlined takes 45 minutes but then life
happens
[ __ ] happens who knows the kid's got a
bloody nose the work call runs over and
you look at your watch and you realize
uh oh I'm only gonna have 15 minutes to
do leg day you have a few options at
that point and the option that I've
taken with meditation is I don't have
enough time I'm not going to meditate
his point is
even if leg day is a warm-up on the
rower and some body weight
split squats that's better than nothing
and the momentum and the consistency
matters so for let's just say meditation
if I were to take that advice which I
have not been although I just had this
conversation with him yesterday or the
day before
even if you sit down and meditate for 30
seconds just check the box like sit down
and do it so that you can build the
confidence
to maintain some degree of momentum and
this applies to diet too right I think
we've all had the experience of being on
some type of diet and maybe you had a
little bit too much to drink or maybe
ate a little too many Edibles and you're
like I just want a cookie and you eat
one cookie and you're like well since I
had one cookie ah well I already screwed
myself so let me eat a whole box of
cookies yeah and the the reverse of that
is well I already have too little time
to get a proper meditation session and
let me do no meditation right and his
point is stick to the schedule reduce
the scope and I think that's very
powerful and I'm going to try
two I'm going to commit let me make a
different statement I'm going to commit
to applying that to meditation in the
new year that's awesome I'd love to hear
that
because I can snowball into some bigger
bigger things down the road yeah totally
totally the thing that I I we can move
on from meditation because it's a pretty
boring topic but
it's literally just sitting there doing
nothing but I would say I would say the
one thing that so I was very fortunate
that I you know you remember we've been
to my page Street Apartment back in the
day on on ESF like I lived right next to
the San Francisco Zen Center like right
next yeah yeah literally right next to
right across the street yeah and so
why I took my first Zen course at that
Zen Center back you know 15 years ago
and I would say that
forever I was doing the com slash well
headspace was my first app experience on
meditation you know and I was doing the
the 10 or 15 minute meditations and I
did that you know consistently pretty
pretty well like not seven days a week
but you know four to five days a week
and it gave me just some nice
moments to just kind of ah you know just
gonna rest a little bit but I gotta say
there's something even there's something
even more special if you can just push
into the next zone of that you know 25
55 minutes like they in in they call
this this word samadhi I'm sure you
probably heard of that before but it's
like this this deep level that I've only
slipped into probably a dozen times and
it's it's I'm like oh [ __ ] like there's
there's that was a little bit of a flex
there no no no no no only only 200 times
or 300 times I mean it's not that's not
even near what the it's just a it's a
okay I'm just [ __ ] it's a deep state
of meditation it's not it's not
Enlightenment or any crazy thing I'm not
flexing that hard but it's like it's a
very it's a it's a very hard thing to to
find and it turns out that the more you
chase it the more it it flees which is
because you're trying for something
versus just relaxing into the moment but
yeah it's true for happiness happiness
in general I would say yeah isn't it
yeah I'll say the one thing that I
really loved about him the way a couple
things to mention about Henry as well is
to give him a little plug he is my
teacher
you mentioned the waking up app I agree
with you wholeheartedly that that was a
turning point for me I started listening
to The Waking Up app I paid for it love
Sam's content I think it's well
researched well it's probably the most
it's the best meditation app for people
that aren't looking to necessarily just
check a box but actually want to go a
little bit deeper because it has the
supporting content that can allow you to
go and take it the conversations and the
essays are excellent and he and he has I
think Henry on the app also yeah well
that was the that's how I discovered
Henry was Henry was Sam somehow found
him as a zen teacher and Henry has
several courses on the waking up app so
if you're curious about who we're
talking to or talking about you can go
and check out Henry's content on the
waking up app and also enjoy the app as
well because it's a great well-made
product that Sam has put together so and
and Henry's voice he has this
mellifluous Dulce tones it's fantastic
he's the kind of guy if he read you the
as Neil Gaiman did once the Cheesecake
Factory menu you'd be like oh I could
listen to this all day he's got a great
voice he's got a great voice
anyway so a couple other things on my
list of New Year's resolutions and then
Tim I'd love to hear your your finalists
as well so two boring things but you
know I think we can all relate
one organizing my photos on the photos
app inside of photos like Jesus it's a
mess
wait wait how are you gonna do that
because I look at my photos and I don't
even take that many photos right I mean
like the the youngsters out there take
whatever it is 20 selfies you send me a
lot of bad stuff
those are usually the most dudes with
the one dude in the center wait what no
those were the whipped cream those were
not dudes oh those weren't dudes no
they're not dudes anyway
those are the most hideous things that
my friends send me in these various
group texts and by the way side note
anyone out there who as their
their personal theater chooses mock
outrage like oh my God I can't believe
every one of you if you had your group
text shared oh my God would go down in
flames like the rest of the world oh
please oh my god dude if I had my
friend's group text shared until you and
I would both it would be game oh
everyone no but here's what would happen
is the entire world would be canceled
right there's not I can't and and I mean
if you wouldn't be canceled I'm like I'm
so sorry your life is so boring and your
friends have no sense of humor well
that's the whole thing is like one one
of the things I love about my friends is
that we can all give each other [ __ ] we
take it and we also share things that
are just so ridiculous they make us
laugh but we're having fun with life
like we're we're just it's it's humor
and we realize that but you know if that
thread got on the internet people would
be like oh my God they made a joke about
this and it's like like it's like I'm
not making any like jokes that I
wouldn't like I have no problem with my
jokes wouldn't be considered to be like
they'd be considered because you could
not the apologies start already no I'm
trying to classify them like they're not
jokes that would people would be like oh
he's he's a a a a woman hater or a
racist or something like that those
aren't the jokes yeah yeah they're more
just like a little bit crude and a
little bit rough around the edges but
it's just a little crazy just a just a
little Cruise your [ __ ] is I can't even
show Daria some of the stuff you said
you can't I should of course you can the
the thing with the two people bumping
and she's like Jesus
oh no that was terrible that was one
that was one of the worst ones you've
ever sent me oh yeah it was so bad you
know something well that's that's that's
I mean kind of relates to my nft project
in a way but it's like you know I you
know it's you know there's something
horrible and special when you're in a
group thread and I I can't I'm not a
woman I don't want to speak for women
men I think just in general are much
greater much rougher I could be wrong
please prove me wrong but
there's some just terrible [ __ ] that
floats around and again it's not
anything that would that would like be
illegal but it's it's just in its own
way jaw drops no no I'm not backbeddling
I'm not backbeddling now that you've got
me started on this whole like
apologizing to the woke supremacist
thing now I've been drafted into this
thankless task but the the point I was
going to make is I don't know if you've
had this experience but you're in a
group thread with a bunch of guys and
it's just constant nonsense right it's
just nonsense dick jokes nonsense
nonsense nonsense and then one person
will throw something in and everyone's
like oh God Jesus God is terrible
totally and then you immediately send it
to five of your friends I immediately
said it to you if that's what when I get
one of those gems I immediately send it
to you well me and Saka like you you do
it yeah yeah yeah yeah we do yeah we do
have some good ones we do have some good
ones
so how the hell did we get on this okay
so we were talking okay I was talking
about organizing my photos oh photos so
wait how would you even do that though
because it seems like such an
overwhelming task is it's not even
probably worth talking about we can I
would just fire up the photos app but
I'm gonna go back in time and start like
going to town and just delete a bunch of
crap definitely not gonna do that okay
continue here's a more important one
though this actually is is something
that I two things well we don't want to
talk about the one but the the one thing
that I do want to do
is I'm really trying to figure out what
was the one you don't want to talk about
well no it's it's I'm I've started
coding again tell me no no nothing not
the plugs that you left
by the way I no we're not gonna get in
that
so this is just going off the rails
quickly so I I am starting to code again
so when I moved from ketos to Tequila
that's when all the trouble starts
exactly
that's how you know this is gonna be a
good episode I'm actually really proud
of us we finally had another holiday
drinking one which is great yeah yeah
next time in person the the one thing I
that that I was going to mention is that
just for fun I am starting coding again
I want to do something generative on the
NFP side which cool and hopefully have
something ready for our conference in
May
um just for fun and then the the last
thing I would say in is something that's
really important to me is
I I want to do this yearly delete of
of things and
I have this Rule and tell me Tim if you
have a better idea physical things
physical things yeah and so what I'm
thinking is that if I haven't used
something in six months
or maybe I should even shortened to
three months let's call it clothing
devices
Etc like any something that's sitting
around in your house like just donate it
like donate it give it away to Goodwill
let it find a the home it belongs in and
reduce your stuff to like
I'd love to cut in half to be honest
like I don't need all the the crap how
do you feel about that
I have some policies for myself that
have been very helpful I think and
sometimes I over correct and I'll
explain why over correcting makes sense
at least for me
the first is
and I'm sure you get this but I I think
I get it to a much greater degree maybe
when you're at the helm of dig this was
an issue I get sent so much [ __ ]
it is unbelievable I mean I just get
mountains of stuff sent we're in the
same boat dude yeah yeah that's part of
why I was thinking about it it's like
you get a lot of books you get a lot of
Swag a lot of things yeah exactly you
get a lot of stuff and so one of my
rules
and I don't follow it perfectly but some
rules followed
imperfectly still add a lot of benefit
and in my case if I'm going to keep
something new I try to get rid of
something so if I'm going to accept one
thing in one thing's got to go if
somebody sends me
maybe it's a really comfortable shirt
that has some clever thing on it and
there's some really minimal branding for
their company and it's a friends thing
and I'm like okay this is a comfortable
shirt maybe I'll keep this
I will try to find a shirt that I get
rid of
because I I have simply too much stuff I
will also go through
periods of purging and I try to do it
leading into the winter because frankly
if you're out there and you have warm
clothing meaning clothing for cold
weather right if you have layers or
thicker clothing or long sleeve shirts
that you are not using and you will not
use this winter
holy [ __ ] there are people who need that
there are people who are homeless there
are people who are without means to buy
clothing for themselves their children
donate that stuff and here's what I
would say if you're on the fence give it
away
right and I don't want to do too much of
the like Maria condo stuff but it's like
if it doesn't spark Joy here's what I
would say this is another I love your
accents by the way they're so good every
time you do one thank you yeah if
anybody didn't know it's not it's not
Marie kondo even though it's very
convenient for the English-speaking
Market it's
yeah she is the most perfect skin of all
time by the way people can find a
photograph of me with her I interviewed
her in Japan have you figured out what
what her secret is genetics maybe I mean
it's it's it's it's it's like
an AI created the perfect human
porcelain doll her it's it's
unbelievable I don't know what it is are
you attracted to her she's cute oh
absolutely I mean she's also married and
like has a family and that's not
something I'm going for but she's a good
like a woman side hustle
Jesus Christ all right anyway so no but
let me let me come back to this and I
have a question for you but go ahead
about buying stuff yeah for sure so the
what I try to do when I look in whether
it's my closet or at things I own
is ask on
on a scale of say one to ten
how much joy am I getting out of this or
how much use am I getting out of this
and then the follow-up question is no
matter what the answer is if it's a 10 I
keep it right if it's a nine I probably
keep it if it's an eight I'd probably
still keep it but if it's less than that
can I could I give this to someone could
I donate this to someone who would
absolutely get an 8 9 or 10. use or joy
out of this if so get rid of it and if
you have some means right and that's
doesn't mean millions of dollars
but
getting rid of a t-shirt or two is
probably not going to break the bank for
a lot of people in which case when in
doubt donate it give it to someone who
can't afford to buy the shirt and if you
decide later you know what oh I really
liked that t-shirt I really like that
v-neck I really like that fill in the
black you can buy it again
and I rarely end up doing that but every
once in a while like I'll do a full
Purge where I'll I'll just take garbage
bags and garbage bags of stuff and
donate it to Goodwill or somewhere else
and then I'll realize ah okay I kind of
got overzealous I got rid of that one
thing that I wore all the time and then
I'll just buy it again on Amazon it's
there two days later it's fine let me
ask you I have a very personal question
and something that I haven't shared
before that I'd like to ask you
about buying things
oh boy wow no I just I just think that
this is something that that no nobody
talks about and I always like to like
you're so good at at finding stuff that
you know you can pick up and and you're
a very open person which I've always
appreciated about your podcast and like
just like how you
transparent about feelings and emotions
and a lot of things that I think a lot
of men could use to look up to you know
in terms of oh God is this question
could be a [ __ ] hydrogen bomb this is
a tough one no no no so here here's
here's a problem that I've had just
being completely honest yeah there was
back when I was in my you know 20s and
early 30s dig was doing quite well
of which is my startup for those of you
don't know was early social News website
that was it was killing it was we had 38
million people a month that we were
visiting the site huge back then it was
one of the top sites on the internet it
was crazy
it started to go sideways and it started
to go down and like not you know like we
were losing to Reddit right it was
starting to kick our ass in some certain
ways and you know we had had dominated
them for many years and then all of a
sudden that was not the case and we were
kind of reeling a little bit
I had sold a tiny bit of my stock
enough to be able to afford an apartment
in in actually buy and put a down
payment on apartment and that's how I
got my page Street Place in NSF and I
remember thinking to myself like I need
to buy myself something it's like it was
a search to feel better right yep and so
I went out and I actually bought and
this is gonna sound super douchey but
I'm okay to say this today like I bought
actually I bought a Porsche I bought a
Porsche 911 back in the day and
looking back on that I realized I was
just in a really difficult sad state
it was it was hard for me you know to
watch this baby of mine and I didn't
know how to course correct it right I
was just so immature in a bunch of
different ways but I was buying for the
sake of trying to fill a gap right don't
get me wrong like I still think vintage
Porsches and old Porsches and Porsches
in general there's beautiful cars like I
I think they're great
I don't I don't have a 911 today but I
will say that
I've noticed the same thing Kevin is not
anti-portion as group text messaging
please don't cancel me Porsche I would
love to be sponsored if you sponsor me
I'm happy to drive 911. so that said you
know here's the crazy thing I went and
ran hodinki the luxury watch brand
company I was CEO there for a few years
and loved my experience there because we
were covering
mechanical like a dying art like it was
like mechanical timepieces and it was
very beautiful in its purest form in its
purest form you talk to an artisan that
is a single independent watchmaker that
takes a year and a half to build
something from scratch and sells 10 a
year that's beautiful like that's that's
those those days are going away and it's
douchey form you're talking to Lambo
drivers that just want to have a flex
that they can hold a watch on their
wrist that says I have five million
dollars on my wrist right like that's a
real thing and so
I met with Allah as his CEO of this
company this is like the you know the it
still is the the largest watch brand
editorial site in the world and
you would meet all these collectors and
they would come up to you and they come
in all different shapes and sizes and it
was clear to me that some of these dudes
like blessed them they were trying to
fill that same thing that I was trying
to fill where you got me spend money on
something to make yourself feel
in a group feel connected to feel
connection because you'd come out and
you'd say is there other collectors like
me like I you know it's tough and and
I'm not anti-watch I still I remember
wearing an app wash today but I I still
have a few time pieces that were really
meaningful to me including one that my
dad left me when he passed away
and and I and I still love that that
whole thing but how do you approach this
as somebody have you ever
spent your money on things and then how
do you approach it with
like have you ever done that and then
also how do you approach that with with
significant others like you know I've
had this conversation with my wife about
like hey we don't have to wear the
flashy stuff it's okay to wear you know
I told her the other night like one of
my my favorite times to hang out with
you is when it's jeans and t-shirts like
version of you at a bar like I love that
yeah having a beer like we don't have to
be fancy la like I don't want that like
where do you stand on on all this stuff
so I think
and and you've probably observed this in
me you're so good at this this is why
I'm trying to pick your brain you don't
do any flashy [ __ ] well I'm good but
there is a
downside
there is a trade-off and I have not
figured out how to contend with this and
I'll actually mention also a book
that has come up several times in the
last week from multiple people
I respect and
remember Rick Rubin the the music
producer said to me when that happens to
him it he feels like it's a
signal from the universe that he needs
to take a look at something and so I
kind of feel like that right now with
this book which I'll come to in a second
I
have had
very few instances of buying expensive
things for myself
and you've seen this oh I know I I don't
think I don't think I'm
stingy in all things
for instance I will go to if I think the
experience is going to leave an
indelible Mark in my mind
I will go to a place like alinea in
Chicago and have a meal and I did that
and I'm really glad I did and it's very
expensive right I mean I would consider
it very expensive it's like fifteen
hundred two thousand bucks for a meal
and that on some level would make the
15 year old version of me going to a
seizure right like did not grow up with
a lot of money
and grew up in a household where
scarcity of money was an issue and my
dad would yell at my mom for spending
too much money on stuff because we she
we literally bounce checks like I
remember that being a conversation like
the account is overdrawn like yeah yeah
it was a source of stress it was a
source of stress and so I decided pretty
early on
as a kid okay
I do not want this type of stress in my
life that means I need to figure out how
to make money
and that in a way was the spark behind
my entrepreneurial
experiments it's like okay this this
type of stress that I have been immersed
in and exposed to
and I don't think it traumatized me I
wouldn't put it that way I wouldn't uh I
wouldn't want to remove the power of
that word trauma by applying it to
something like this and I think it kind
of disgusts me how overused the word
trauma is
that's a separate thing but
it affected me it definitely imprinted
something on me and
as a result
I have spent relatively little money
celebrating anything right the fact that
I spent like these Japanese Saddles
right I bought them at auction from an
OP from I can't remember it was
Christie's or Sotheby's
and I think it was
five thousand dollars a piece right is
and and to to allow myself to do that
the hurdle was not only do I have to
finish and publish a book that is 500
plus pages I think there's maybe 700
Pages which was cut down from probably
1500 pages was this in your head or did
something you wrote down
like this is a hurdle that you had to
like you're like it was in my head but I
I said if if I publish this book and it
is number one New York Times I will
allow myself
as a reward to buy these Saddles that
cost five thousand dollars each and if I
don't
I'm not allowed to do this
so on some level I respect that and it's
very
strict high standards and on some level
all of those things are good but
what I will say is
when I meet
or spend time with friends of mine
who have achieved some degree of success
and it it's it's not always millions of
dollars right they've they've just
figured out
a job and a seal where they've developed
a career and they're stable and they fix
a lot of problems for themselves and
they add a lot of joy for themselves and
their families by spending money
the dark side of what I'm describing is
that I don't think I've developed that
very well and so I have
and I have more money than I know what
to do with and I think I put I put it I
don't want to sound like a prick that
doesn't mean that I'm just like doing
backstroke through a pool full of gold
coins like Scrooge McDuck that's not
what I'm saying I put I think I am a
very very
hopefully this doesn't sound pompous I I
think I'm a very very good
capital allocator and Steward of money I
think I use
what I have to very high Leverage
means and and and
objectives through funding the science
and the journalism fellowship with
Michael pollen and so on like but but
here's what I'll say Kevin is is
there's there's a dark side to it in
that I I don't use money to fix problems
that I should fix
like what give me an example
you know I'll give an example which
would be
there are little things I'll give you a
perfect example so
there's an article it's not really an
article it's more an adaptation of
John Stuart Mill's ideas on Free Speech
which is an Illustrated Edition it's
called all minus one you can find it on
Amazon you can also get it for free I
think it's at
heterodoxacademy.org Mill
and this came about
through a conversation with Jonathan
height who's fascinating thinker and
professor and researcher who wrote the
coddling of the American mind and many
other books
so this is let's see on Kindle it's
I think 78 pages
and
I agonized over when I was going to find
time to print this and
put it together in a hard copy so that I
could mark it up because I didn't want
to wait for the paperback
this is stupid I have employees I could
send this to someone and just be like
hey figure this out whatever makes it
readable go right it would have taken 30
seconds but there's part of me for
whatever reason that gets stuck on doing
it myself and doesn't even consider that
it doesn't enter my head as an option
and there are many other examples of
this right I've been to friends houses
where
they love let's not name names but not
because you'll probably get it but like
but I have I have a friend who really
loves topachico and you go to his house
and he always has a refrigerated drawer
full of Topo Chico yeah it's never empty
he never runs out it's extra sparkly
it's good it is yeah it'll definitely
take all the enamel off your teeth it's
delicious and
and even though all the hips are awesome
nights have boycotted it because it's
owned by the evil empire of colonos and
they're you know they're drinking uh
Richard's rainwater and and others which
are fine fine fine sparkling water but I
just I just find the outrage pretty
hilarious
but the point is like he has
a team he pays people to help
him and his family with their lives in
various ways so that he can focus on
things he's really good at which does
not include
figuring out at the last minute oh [ __ ]
I'm out of Topo Chico how am I gonna
make it in time to the grocery store to
buy this and chew up 45 minutes of my
time
I don't have many of those systems in
place and it's not because I am
consciously deciding I need to save
money it's like the option doesn't even
appear
on my mental
UI to choose so this is something I'm
trying to figure out which leads to the
book
which has been recommended a number of
times now which is called die with zero
have you I've not read it I've heard
about this actually so full disclosure
I've not Chris Hutchin sent this to me
oh no [ __ ] okay so Bill Perkins
is the author and I should know better
than to recommend something
before I've read it so I just want to
make it super clear I have not read this
but the book is
die with zero getting all you can from
your money and your life and it's
written by Bill Perkins who's a famous
energy Trader slash investor
and the
Wall Street Journal bestseller I'll just
read a little bit of the description
which is very
seductive to me because it's written by
someone who has also been an operator
if this book were written by just
someone who's
waxing poetic without any real Bona
fides Bona fides I would be skeptical
but
this is someone who's actually been a
real operator in the trenches so the
description is a common sense guide To
Living Rich instead of dying Rich
imagine if by the time you died you did
everything you were told to you worked
hard saved your money and looked forward
to Financial Freedom when you retired
the only thing you wasted along the way
was dot dot dot your life
die with zero presents a startling new
and provocative philosophy as well as
practical guide and how to get the most
out of your money and the most out of
your life it's intended for those who
place lifelong memorable experiences far
ahead of Simply making and accumulating
money for one so-called golden years and
it goes on yes
this is interesting to me and I'm I'm
hoping that it provides me with some
counter programming that will maybe help
me to do more and I have I will say
been finding some Outlets where I don't
have Hang-Ups and one is spending money
on art or supporting artists so I'll be
I will be doing moving forward
quite a few experiments with artists and
artwork I did one that is actually
running right now as we record it's
going to end in a few hours but it's a
competition
for AI generated or enhanced artwork
[ __ ] punch related or no [ __ ] punch
related are you serious yeah yeah
complex related and the stuff that has
come out is
beyond belief I mean it is hard to wrap
my head around and I say this is someone
who has quite a bit of art background
and worked as an illustrator paid a lot
of bills as an illustrator for magazines
and books in college
it is hard to wrap my head around what
this technology will do for Creative
expression and it's controversial I have
seen blowback right because AI
whether it's chat GPT for text or other
tools requires training data so where do
you get that training data if it's
graphical expression if it's
if it's what we would consider visual
art they might be pulling from say
artists on Art station right but it's
blending it so well together that you
could never pick out individually which
artist is pulling from so in some
sometimes in less than your prompt you
say right instead of in the style of Van
Gogh which most people would consider
fair game if it's in the style of fill
in the blank contemporary artists who
makes their living selling prints
in part or doing commissioned artwork
is that a net positive or a net negative
for them I don't know I'm not going to
talk to you you know who's fun to chat
with this is I was talking to Mike
Shinoda about this our mutual friend
from Lincoln Park and he was talking
about how he there's this list you can
sign up for that apparently will exclude
you from the training data if you really
want out it's like the Do Not Call List
yeah exactly he was saying that like
because in music you could imagine this
is going to be a big deal right you're
going to say it's hey I'm already seeing
stable diffusion applied to music in
ways that make your head spin and it's
so early it's not even the first inning
yeah I mean I was asking him about like
hey what do you think of AI when it says
Hey play me a song like it was written
by Mike Shinoda and what does that sound
like you know and he's it's it's a it's
a big topic to go into how does he feel
I don't want to speak for him but he was
at that time it seemed like
you know I I I got the sense and I'm
just I'm paraphrasing here I'm actually
not even paraphrase I would say that I
got the sense that it's early days and
yeah I if anything I I know about Mike
is like he's he's definitely he Embraces
the future there's no doubt about it
like he's all web three he's doing and
if he drops he's doing generous stuff
like with music it's it's yeah he's
awesome on that front
but at the same time I can imagine if
you're an artist in his position which
is you know just the top tier top one
percent of all musical artists out there
you kind of also want to protect who you
are as an individual in your IP that was
the kind of sense I got from him is like
figuring out how to how this is gonna
weave and and what you're gonna have to
do in the future so yeah he'd be a fun
one to have on and eventually talk about
this I should I should have him back on
the podcast like 100 years ago I should
have them back on oh he's such a good
dude yeah great guy and on the AI front
I will say right I I have artists in my
family
I see how hard it is I've been there
myself
and
I should point out also that I am not
necessarily
immune to the influence of these
Technologies in the sense that
I have seen blog posts generated using
predominantly AI with very few prompts
and things are going to change for
writers oh my God it's so in a big way
and that will particularly apply to
non-fiction writers and I am principally
a non-fiction writer and a fiction
writers dude like a lot of this these
tools are being done around fiction and
fiction fiction is going to be harder I
think fiction will be a lot harder to
thread but both will be affected and
this so there are many questions that
this
this prompts pun intended
one is
what are the factors that will drive say
reading in my case how much of it will
be
being certain that you are reading
something generated by a human before
you're willing to commit to having an
emotional response even if the output is
identical right will there be some
authenticity of human production
that becomes important I could see that
becoming important interesting like do
you really want to cry watching a movie
that was a hundred percent produced by
robots Maybe not maybe that is a hard
line that people draw where they're like
I I don't actually want to have my
emotions manipulated by machines yeah
but you already do today with with the
the graphics right those are creative
machines oh yeah so no it's it's it's a
question of degree right we're already
being affected what you're saying Tim is
let's just jump forward 20 20 years from
now you're saying there is a world where
you can imagine a novel that would have
some type of designation on it you know
digitally that would say this was human
written like just to ensure absolutely
oh that's [ __ ] crazy that's awesome
absolutely I mean imagine you have these
timepieces
that are
One of a Kind produced by the labor of
one or a handful of people over a year
and a half
the origin and the story matter
you could produce something maybe even
Superior
with Advanced Robotics and software and
so on but you want
you want the physical and psychic
imprint of these human hands the human
connection yeah exactly yeah so I think
absolutely like just like you have a
stamp for organic or you know Humane
certified or free trade it'd be like
human generated stamp I I would be
surprised if that's not a thing I think
it'll be a thing you should go and
file your trademarks and patents
[Laughter]
so that'll be that'll be a thing let me
let me add a few more though so another
one will be
well actually this is more philosophical
so I thought about
the counter arguments in the blowback
related to AI before I launch this
competition
and I understood
the counter arguments and I don't
disagree with them this is going to
affect the competitive landscape for
artists period full stop sure especially
especially for things like logo design
well yeah of course Fiverr is [ __ ]
yeah like website lit layout and so on
the the way I'm looking at it is
if I Tim wanted to help as many artists
as possible
what would my chess move be and where I
landed was
we are going from the horse and the
horse-drawn carriage to the car that
transition is happening whether we
wanted to or not that's right and if we
own a bunch of horses if we own a bunch
of carriages if we own the equivalent of
a taxi service back in the day that's
fine
but the technology is going to change so
if you want to be in a competitive
position if you want to have advantages
you need to be on the
front end of learning about these
Technologies yeah which is part of the
reason why I wanted to do this
competition to say hey guys
you can make this work for you in a lot
of ways
but you got to be on the early end
you just have to there's a couple things
that I think are important to point out
here in that to me this just represents
another leap
forward in technology
almost the way I would say the the
closest
parallel I have to this is probably the
graphical user interface that was done
by you know the mac and and and Netscape
yeah web browser well imagine when you
were an artist back in the day and to
draw a circle meant you had to sit down
and try and draw a circle right and you
know in photos
yeah you can exactly you needed a
compass and like now in Photoshop
the compass references it's great but
but now you can you can literally oh
pencil's too short I'm getting a wobbly
Circle let me sharpen that thing right
so those days are gone and and that's
okay and and no I'm sure there was some
artists that were like you know [ __ ]
Photoshop for making that perfect circle
like I used to have to draw those you
know and like that's kind of what we're
going through today with this next jump
it's like there's gonna be it's gonna be
tough for a few years it's gonna feel
weird it's gonna feel not right and and
then finally we'll understand what the
tool actually is you know and I and also
I will just say if you're early you can
learn how to use the tools rather than
be abused by
the adoption of the tools
it's super important if you learn early
holy [ __ ] you have tremendous
Advantage so learn early start
experimenting now I'll give you another
prediction I was thinking about this
imagine
if you will I feel like Dan Carlin with
Hardcore History imagine if you will
General subadai no let me come back so
imagine imagine that you have
a book you have a non-fiction book it's
a biography of a contemporary figure
Teddy Roosevelt whatever like Theodore I
think it's Theodore Rex I think is this
multi-volume biography that I've been
meaning to read forever and I just keep
putting it off because it's it's so long
and I've heard it's amazing
but I haven't been willing to commit
it's just too long
I think there will be a time probably in
the next year wouldn't surprise me
within the next year I would imagine for
books that are well reviewed have a lot
of coverage and are contemporary meaning
within the last hundred years
I will be able to say
something along the lines of with a
a prompt interface
to stabled Fusion or any number of other
tools
and I think a lot of these tools will
get combined into user interfaces where
the mechanics the underlying mechanics
are invisible oh my god dude wait pause
for one second okay can I get this
little slip something in real quick yeah
yeah I think it's there is a service you
have to try
I don't know if you remember our buddy
Addison Kowalski he created prompt
prompthunt.com
and it actually is it's it's it's taking
exactly what you said where right now
it's is it's 50 words to create this
prompt this perfect time
it's around it and it's really genius
really really cool yeah okay
this will do well yeah if it's executed
well prop.com will do well because the
magic isn't the prompt it's kind of like
being a magician with the spell I mean
yes you have to get the incantation
right and if you don't zero you come up
empty-handed or you get some [ __ ]
module monstrosity side note really
quickly rhino skin solutions.com is what
I was referring to earlier the dry spray
and the Mikey's tip juice sounds porno
is what I have so there you go we we
what are you talking about you're
talking about the hand stuff yeah the
the the antiperspirant for the hands
that was a that was a big callback that
was that was it was a big call in the
back okay so let me do one more then one
more quick call back
side note this is the last one I promise
for all those that were we talked about
the Tim you mentioned the book die with
zero
our friend Chris Hutchins the reason I
said that he had mentioned it to me he
actually did a podcast with them so oh
no [ __ ] I know you I know you love Chris
he has a podcast about all the hacks so
all the hacks a die with zero is the one
to to check out anyway oh cool I'll
check it out yeah Chris's Chris is very
diligent he is I will it's like a mini
you
honestly like I want to give him more
credit he's he's the first Chris
Hutchins he is I thought I was OCD about
prep
he he he he's given me a run for my
money he really does a lot of
preparation and his meticulous in how he
approaches the details of these things
so I will check out that podcast and
we'll link to it in the show notes
AI prediction
big book yes three volumes biography
[ __ ] I'm never going to listen to that
I'm never going to read that
I could put in a prop which is something
like
create a Ken Burns like documentary
that allows me to cover the most
important parts of fill in the blank
book or book series
with say archival photographs or footage
with a voice overlay that provides
narration which is pulling from the
highlights of that book using sources
like quotes from Goodreads and Kindle
highlights this is gonna [ __ ] you by the
way it's totally gonna [ __ ] me it's
totally gonna [ __ ] me I mean I am I am
absolutely
going to be simultaneously the
beneficiary
and the [ __ ] punch recipient of
artificial intelligence yeah you're
going to be on the 100 oh it's it's it's
gonna rock the boat in such a
significant way but what I'm committed
to doing
is being a student of the craft because
it is the it is the Model T and the car
coming after horse-drawn carriages and
this is inevitable it is not reversible
sadly you know there's no Lobby there's
no Lobby I can think of no it's open
source Genie's out of the bottle it's
out of the bottle it's out of the bottle
so there's that
yeah should we talk about
coccasital Maniacs yeah let's talk about
your [ __ ] punch let's let's have anybody
name name that movie reference [ __ ]
style Maniac do you get that reference
no I don't maybe you're older than I am
ouch I'm older than you are give me a
break look at those white whiskers you
got over there Mr sea otter
at least I have here [ __ ] I got here
underneath there yeah yeah that's true
you do have you do have a nice Los
Angeles slick going with the black hair
what the [ __ ] was I just talking about
oh yeah Cox Auto Maniac very important
film reference this is a reference it
takes place in a bar scene in the
Winchester in Shawn of the dead
s-h-a-u-n of the Dead one of the
greatest of all time I watched it
several hundred times as background when
I was writing the four hour work week
that's awesome little known fact
okay do you have it you have gray hairs
yet or no oh my God I'm covered in gray
hairs man yeah I I was fortunate slash
unfortunate to lose my hair before my
hair went gray on my head but oh chest
hair beard hair salt and pepper
Mania absolutely you get the uh the
grays
the Gray's down under I've had a couple
percent here and of course I do how
would you have anybody who's like yeah I
have gray my beard and Gray in my chest
but my my pubes are like the Mane of
black stallion give me a [ __ ] break
that's why I swear I only have had like
two and it's it's depressing it's
depressing because you trim them real
quick because you're going to get them
out of there but like oh I gave up on
that did you you just full grate your
Santa down there Santa's a little bit
I'm just like I'm like I'm like Adam
Gonzalez beard on my balls
[Laughter]
NFC land been for you so so well let me
ask you this first if you got any
blowback oh I'm happy to talk about all
of it I I will say just just to preface
the whole thing I am still having so
much fun there was there was like a
death valley of
anger and like the trough of Sorrow for
sure yeah the taint of Sorrow it's like
you have to travel through the taint of
Sorrow was sorrowful so I'm not going to
downplay that we can talk about it but
yeah what did you expect was gonna
happen let me let me start there because
you've you've been through this Rodeo
multiple honestly now Tim I I kind of
knew you were [ __ ] I I I would have
said something if I thought it was
career ending for you yeah and I didn't
think that what I thought was that
I told Daria this actually my wife this
I said you know I'm glad that Tim has
enough money to not give a [ __ ] because
it it is he's having fun and all you can
ask for for for anyone
yeah I think about this with my kids a
lot at the end of the day because like
Daria is an academic and she you know
got her PhD in neuroscience and I
clearly am not I'm a College Dropout and
at the end of the day what I want for my
children is them for Define their life's
work and their fun in life like their
Joy did you see them for it to find what
I'm like deep into this bottle of
fantastic wine which I will say is the
mascot so
all all jokes aside
um I I I love when I see Tim having a
good time because Tim I've known you for
a long time man and I know that you're
both you're a very interesting cat and
that you're like both insanely playful
but insanely serious at the same time
and you have these two sides of your
life that you just like you know
sometimes are at odds with each other
and anytime you want to see playful Tim
come out I'm just like I'm happy I'm a
happy person because I love to see you
happy and and if this is like that for
you it's it makes me happy so that's
great well what's what's also
a timing hilarity in all of this is that
as I'm about to go into
this huge experiment that I've been
working on forever
and Kevin's my Sherpa right Kevin
on there too well no no okay I'm gonna
give Brennan credit where credit is due
but but you got me interested in along
with Naval and other people interested
in web3
you led me to my first actually rewind
the clock you led me to my first crypto
purchases
in late 2012 early 2013 somewhere in
that range
you have introduced me to a lot of very
important
technological innovations you also
walked me through as my metamask tech
support
my first nft purchase I believe it says
that by the way
[Music]
VIP White Glove tech support and
then I'm getting ready the launch is
coming holy [ __ ] I'm nervous people on
your team are helping me and then
Kevin's like I'm going on a silent
Meditation Retreat for seven days and
I'm like what
so Kevin disappears but let me catch you
up so
pre-med Brendan Mulligan I have to give
him a lot of credit we both known him
for a long time
he's a great human yes gives a [ __ ] he
cares about quality
he is very thoughtful he and his team I
want to give his team credit too he and
his team executed flawlessly they were
so detail oriented which of course I
appreciate don't forget about my team we
did no your team was amazing hold on
hold on hold on I'm just you mentioned
Brendan so I'm mentioning Brennan first
so Brendan executed so well and his team
prototyping the mint Pages as a
potential offering through pre-med
incredible so I just want to give a
thanks there I'll also give thanks of
course
to your entire team the sort of
Divergence super squad that was that was
absorbed was eaten brought onto the
island of proof by KK roro kevkev rose
rose okay
is that a new one that's a new one you
sounded like the South Park guys doing
some of their voiceovers
anyway some people will get that and
the the Divergence team
also world class I mean good job by the
way I'm just glad you had a great mint
man everything went fine you sold out
like everything went great it sold out
we I think managed it very well people
get pissed no matter what but I think we
managed it as well and planned it as
well as we possibly could have you know
how much I agonized over this I mean I
went
I held on to multiple variables as
undefined into all the the 11th hour
because I really wanted to
try to satisfy as many people as
possible with that it is not possible to
make everyone happy especially in web3
especially in nfts
but the mint went off with that hitch
and then the reveal drops a few days
later oh let me back up and just say
thank you to everyone who participated
in the primary sale because it raised
1.8 or so million dollars for the size
Foundation all of those funds have
already been wired to the size a
foundation that happened within I want
to say 48 Hours 72 hours
and money is already being distributed
to projects so this is not a foundation
that sits on funds those funds are going
to immediate use and I'll be I'll be
sharing more about that and the uses for
people who don't know they can find size
a foundation at
s-a-i-s-e-i foundation.org because I say
means rebirth in Japanese has funded and
continues to fund critical early stage
research related to treating conditions
like treatment resistant depression
complex PTSD so-called intractable
conditions that effectively fail with
our first line treatments currently and
a lot of that is psychedelic assisted
therapy related but not all of it
as the I personally and size Foundation
have been involved in funding
Mr White pubes himself God he's going to
love that Dr Adam gazali and his amazing
work at neuroscape I'm sorry Adam we had
to do it it's okay but but he is I mean
he's such a superstar he can get away
with it right like that guy is a that
guy is an absolute top tier world-class
scientist who knows how to navigate all
of the complexities
and uh
therefore thanks huge sincere thanks to
everybody who participated it's all
going to very very high leverage high
impact stuff and then the reveal comes
right and the reveal comes the art comes
out
some people love it some people hate it
I still stand by the art I stand by it
one thing that happened that I did not
anticipate
at all is that
a few things and I'll I'll I will point
out that I'm paying attention to
feedback I don't pay attention to like
you suck balls man [ __ ] you I don't pay
attention to that and I'll block you if
you do that but I do pay attention to
valid feedback and there's a lot of
valid feedback for instance
because this project is not a pfp
project it's not a profile pic project
even though pfb stands for proof for
picture I think or picture from no
profile no no it does not it does not no
it stands for it stands for picture for
proof look it up ended up being co-opted
into profile pic there's no F in profile
pic project
so it profile Jesus of course you would
know the technical [ __ ] it just means
show me your face on the [ __ ] Twitter
like well that's what it means now I'm
just I just wanted to throw a monkey
wrench into things for a second because
I know you're deep in the wine so I
wanted to stumble things
the point being because it wasn't a
profile pic
and I tried to explain this is an elf
right it's an emergent long fiction
project and to explain that it didn't
fit neatly into any category no that
people could
absorb in a millisecond for that reason
when the art was displayed full body it
was actually I think confusing to some
people
even though I'd explained they would be
full body and furthermore the resolution
was ratcheted really far down to be a
unique file type that allows
openc in this case the ability to
monitor for counterfeits so the function
is really important the function is
super important they can flag and remove
counterfeits and imitations and scams
by utilizing this unique file type but
what it did is it ratcheted down and I
should give a huge thanks to the open
seat team they were outstanding and
helping with this project
in
a million different ways so I want to
give them full credit where credit is
due and also the fact that this file
type which is incredibly High utility
and import for the platform and for
projects because immediately had dozens
of scams just as moonbirds did
there are a lot there are a lot of
fly-by-night grifters in this space and
anywhere there's anonymity you're going
to run into this but once you add money
to the mix [ __ ] gets crazy very quickly
so that was a good thing right in the
sense that that file type allowed us to
contend with and prevent
or I shouldn't say prevent but minimize
confusion in the marketplace
the side effect of that though is that
the resolution is quite low
and as a result people were not able to
see a lot of the detail of the artwork
especially because it was full body
and we addressed that later by providing
a token ID lookup where people could say
hey I own [ __ ] Punch or the legend of
[ __ ] punch number 234 let me go to
cockmush.com pfp put in my number I get
a high resolution image I also get a pfp
camera angle from within blender for
this character cool yeah which has been
super fun we once one question there so
if I put in my number will that give me
a cropped version of the head so I can
use it as if exactly it'll give the best
crop version of that and also the best
camera angle from within blender which
is 3D modeling software
and then what I did because I had
created these
these
AI Blended
oil paintings of some of these
characters for each of the houses so
there are eight primary houses in this
world much like Game of Thrones
and I created what you might consider
even like a portrait painting
equivalent of each of these
iconic houses and I did that by using
night Cafe I think it's also called
night Studio which largely uses stable
diffusion but also Dolly too and a few
others
to blend the original artwork with Van
Gogh's self-portrait oh that's amazing
how did I not see this where that's
probably when I was at my meditation
review
so if you go to if you go to and we can
talk about Twitter because I know that's
might be on the docket we should talk
about it actually if you go to Twitter
and then say if you go to clock Bunch
not not slash [ __ ] Punch If you go to
I'm just waiting on my browser to
respond wow is my browser slower is
Twitter really slow right now
might be Twitter
or it could be that my account is
suspended for the 12th time that's been
happening a lot Elon
elon's Elon hates [ __ ] punches
okay I'm having trouble getting Twitter
display but if you go to twitter.com
[Laughter]
[Music]
if you go to twitter.com
we need t-shirts for just for the random
shows wow
slouch house hallux like
h-a-l-l-u-x if it maybe it'll pop up for
you okay I went to slash
h-a-l-l-u-x twitter.com house hallux so
house okay h-a-l-l-u-x because if you
just do a helix it's a guy's toes on
there yep that makes sense okay all
right so do you see what I'm talking
about you see sort of okay oh it's
beautiful that's amazing isn't that
gorgeous oh it's so good it's so good so
if people go to twitter.com househalex
house is one of the eight greater houses
and each of these houses has its
background coming out on the [ __ ] punch
podcast which by the way you were gone
for this but debuted at number one in
fiction across all of Apple podcasts
ended up at
top 50
or top 60 across all of Apple podcasts
and people are now listening to these
and getting really into it people are
enjoying it and particularly once I made
the and my team I should give them
credit the higher res full body images
and pfps available
I put out a video on YouTube which
showed people how to convert their pfp
into this van Gogh self-portrait styled
oil painting and people have been having
a blast they've been having so much fun
and things have gone pretty
bananas there is a lot of creativity I'm
gonna buy some more [ __ ] punches there's
a lot of creativity being Unleashed and
this was the hope and hence the
description of the project as emergent
long fiction immersion not just emergent
from me but emergent from the audience
so for instance there is this unofficial
Discord I said from the outset I wasn't
going to make a Discord because
everybody told me Discord is where all
the evil comes out
and I have how however ended up
chancing upon this unofficial Discord
where they had I might have sent this to
you and Brendan via text
they had AI driven cockfights with
different [ __ ] punch characters on this
Discord and I have never seen anything
like this it was so funny that I was
sweating through my clothing I mean it
was beyond hilarious and rock climbing
yeah yeah it was like rock climbing but
but a lot more hilarious and what they
did it was genius so they had people
opt-in to competing so let's say they
have brackets like an NCAA tournament
and
each character would feed in their name
and their traits so the traits and
attributes that you would find on say
openc
and then the moderator who was also the
commentator kind of like a sports
commentator
would feed this into chat GPT and he
would add a prompt like describe an epic
battle between
or among and list all these characters
with their traits and then chat GPT
would spit out this fight scene and he
then on Discord in a voice channel would
read this for everybody as it's
happening as it's being generated so
there's a live sports element to it
there was somebody else in the channel
who because a bunch of these characters
especially from the amikawa
have an instrument which is called a
shamisen which is a traditional Japanese
instrument somehow he managed to pull up
this super aggressive traditional
shamisen music so you have this
commentator who's reading the live
fights like the play-by-play like a
boxing match from the 1950s while this
crazy Japanese music is playing and
simultaneously the text thread is going
crazy with all these people commenting
and throwing in memes it was beyond
hilarious and so exciting
and [ __ ] fun it was so fun and I had
nothing to do with it I mean look I
provided a few of the raw materials
perhaps in the form of a funny name some
artwork the attributes and the naming of
the attributes by the way not accidental
if people look at the attributes they
have not paid most people have not paid
enough attention to the naming of the
weapons and the attributes I spent at
least 10 hours just on naming
so that will become more relevant later
but the way that this is unfolding
has been
super fun it's been super fun there was
a period of time where I was just like
[ __ ] all these nft Traders [ __ ] these
people I was so annoyed because there
was so much
unnecessary spinning of conspiracy
theories like team's gonna send all the
money to his own charity and buy a
Lamborghini and run off to Bermuda this
whole thing's a scam it's a rug pull and
I'm like what are you talking about I
put everything in the FAQ I told you all
of the conditions all of the objectives
stop it just [ __ ] stop it but there's
there is I think I would imagine you
tell me but inevitably this cycle of
like over exuberance
as soon as the floor price drops by .001
East like 10 of the people lose their
[ __ ] minds and become children here's
the thing here's the thing this is the
best advice I can give you Tim is that
having been here in my wise old age of
six months longer than you have
seven months which is like 10 years in
nft exact time I can tell you that what
happens is you there are a lot of
flippers that come in obviously that are
looking like how can I two or three
excess in in two minutes right yeah and
then eventually you'll realize and it's
really cool that we're starting to see
this happen in Moon Birds where the a
lot of that is kind of like that chatter
has gone away and it's more about the
long-term holders that understand that
like you know great projects great
Visions great businesses they're not
built over six months they're built over
the next decade right yeah they take
time so if we're gonna do that like they
they they're signing up and believing in
us as Builders over the long term and I
think that's that's where you'll get to
is you'll get to people that are like oh
I love the podcast I love the lore I
love the backstory I love what Tim's
doing here I'm I'm a holder for the long
term and what you'll see is your percent
listed will drop over time right and
that will be because you're getting in
to more of the long-term holders that
believe in the the project of long over
over the next decade which is very
exciting and I already see that
happening with your collection today
which is great the one thing I will say
that was is amazing
is you had one of your golden [ __ ]
which is your signature [ __ ] go for 55 e
which is just it's why
55.550 eth is one of what your your Cox
went for and it has the the gold balls
attribute it's full gold that is
full gold well copper too right
it might be copper it might be copper
yeah there's there are a couple of
different options there's there's
let's see here there's gold
pewter I believe which is this the
silver equivalent but I thought pewter
was much cooler and then copper because
I love copper that's a long story but I
I really have an affinity for copper
there are a bunch of metals I've
finished for copper as one one question
I have for you is you have an attribute
called the circle of eight but yes my my
zen hat on says that's a that's an inso
so is it an inso or no an Enzo describe
for the artist and so is it's just like
the the Japanese symbol for
like you can look up go go and type in
enso and so yep and and into Google
images and you'll see it's like the you
know it's the standard Zen Circle the
one's a single stroke can you pull up
one of those characters
as you're looking at them
yeah I have them up right now yeah okay
look at the shirt what's on the shirt
can you see what's on it it's it's green
hold on let me get back to it ahead yeah
it's a green shirt and it's got the
single oh is this a dragon it's a circle
dragon eating its own tail okay my bad I
thought it was more of the single stroke
like Zen symbol you don't have you don't
well right it may not be
it may not be unrelated that is a dragon
eating its own tail yes in what is
called an oroboros and there are a lot
of kind of hyper
proud liberal arts folks who
use this word or mythological reference
in snarky magazine articles but they
don't actually have a full understanding
of the mythological significance and
variation on this this concept of the
oroboros so people can look into it
but you're going to ask about them I
will say that I think the circle of
eight are overlooked
well there's only seven of them though
why aren't there eight of them there is
an eighth he's in there he's in there
somewhere he's not tagged as Circles of
eight though he's not and it could be
she no he it can't be a sheep because
they're all [ __ ] but yes
so there's not a single ballis one out
of all them they're all there's not a
single what
ballless one yeah yeah they're all [ __ ]
like they're all they're all male it's
cockbuck yes they're all they're all
they're all they're all cocked
you're like Kevin maybe the title may
have tipped you off
Punch
Yeah I mean it's it's it's very much but
that is one of the outstanding mysteries
in the realm of varlotta which as
described by the seventh scribe in the
first episode of the podcast is there
are several
very significant outstanding questions
and one is
where are the women right we assume we
got here by birth if we did There's
season two for you question mark
question mark question mark oh
interesting lady bunch I could go way
worse
cutslap.com
you're definitely gonna bleep that one
out
no I just love saying that because I
know that some aspirational squatters
gonna go out and buy [ __ ] slap
everything he'd be like you didn't get
cutslop.eth now you can buy it from me
for twenty thousand dollars and I'll be
like enjoy that one I'm never gonna use
it that's how they do it but I have a
lot of ideas I'm not committing to a
decade of building X Y or Z I've made
this clear from the outset I'm gonna do
this as long as it's energy feeding
which I think is part of the reason why
a lot of Traders have ditched which I'm
thrilled about
and not to say that Traders are trivial
they for they they they
provide liquidity and a really important
function and I understand why they do
what they do but as somebody pointed out
on Twitter who is a holder of one of
these [ __ ] punch entities they said with
every secondary transaction you are
getting closer to the community that you
want mm-hmm that's very good and I
thought about that I was like [ __ ]
that's true damn did you tweet that out
because that's some same [ __ ] I need to
tweet out it wasn't mine it was somebody
else I I apologize that I can't remember
the proper attribution but it's like
with every secondary sale you are
getting closer to the community that you
want and it's so true when you think
about it even if I look at the last when
did this even happen God it seems like
six months since I launched but it's
only been
three weeks two weeks yeah exactly you
know I will say
oh man when I talk to people who have
been deep in the trenches with nfts for
like six months a year two years
it is like looking at a before and after
photo of Obama when he got elected and
four years later yeah it's like it's
like people yeah people are worn down
they've got the thousand yard stare yeah
like all their black hair is all gone
gray I'm like holy [ __ ] you really gotta
pace yourself yeah oh my God it's so
intense I'm excited for you man I think
this is a a fun creative chapter for you
and I love that you're not saying this
is my next great book this one it's just
a fun Outlet right like it's it's a fun
outlet but I want to rewind and and and
say something Echo something that you
said and we hadn't had that much booze
this was in Santa Monica and
I don't know if we were recording but I
was showing you some of the artwork and
I was getting excited I was explaining
some of the stuff I was thinking about
and you said and maybe you were joking
you can tell me you're like this might
be the biggest thing that you've done
and
I don't think
that's a zero percent no I likelihood I
meant that when I said that I know that
sounds [ __ ] crazy but I don't think
it's zero percent I really don't now the
reason I I I say that is because and I I
truly did mean that when I said it is
because of one simple thing and this is
like it's funny
you know just in full transparency a
handful of friends are like what's Tim
doing what's this [ __ ] punch thing you
know they come up to me because they
know I know you and they're like wanting
to know like is this crazy like what is
he gone off the deep end I'll block I'm
like I'm like my answer is always very
succinct and and it's on point and then
I say
you don't understand like
Tim is a creativity Factory and if you
point that in the right direction those
are those triceps by the way yo look at
this triceps God look at that forearm
and those triceps if you point that in
the right direction you're gonna have
just something that could turn into a
franchise and something that is much
bigger than you're even imagining
oftentimes
we see this in technology all the time
whether it be Twitter or Instagram or
you name it I can probably point to 15
companies that everyone thought when
they launched that it was a fun little
fad
and then it snowballs into something
bigger and bigger and bigger and all of
a sudden it would not Shock me if five
years from now and I know you're not
saying this is me saying this but you're
in some major Motion Picture crazy [ __ ]
multi like print book like world where
this blows up into something much bigger
and so when I looked at that I said wow
this is this is you if you take your
non-fiction world and move it to fiction
this is your creativity shifting to that
fiction World which I want to watch I
want to watch every chapter of that you
know yeah so I'm excited for you thanks
man yeah it's
or it could be nothing or it could be
nothing right but that's that's the best
part is it is you haven't promised that
this is the future you're saying I'm
gonna have a great time and let's see
what happens I have the emergency exit
if I get sick of it I'm out and what you
described and the floor goes to zero
Maybe
I don't think that's inevitable I do not
think that's inevitable because my goal
is to create something that can
perpetuate without me that's always the
objective right I when's the last time I
gave an interview for the four hour work
week right 10 years ago right
still one of the top books on Amazon
right it's a great point so my intention
and here's the thing there's a cohesion
and a shared incentive and an alignment
with nfts that does not quite exist with
books
and that's very interesting to me so
I'm studying this very deeply I think a
lot of conversations
I could ditch in a month if I deal with
like a thousand consecutive dick faces
on the internet maybe yeah
but so far it's been pretty easy
relative to all the things that I've had
to contend with over the last say decade
it's been pretty easy to discard that
just because the nonsense is clearly
nonsense yeah and the people spotting
nonsense are generally spouting that
nonsense to other people who are
spotting nonsense right
and
even in two weeks just being able to
withstand the heat in the kitchen and
staying in the kitchen oh then you know
you're good A lot of that has resolved
itself it's gonna calm down exactly yeah
in 10 days it's already calmed down
and so for me this is when the
interesting stuff starts right this is
when things start to get interesting
when I have a critical mass of people as
evidenced by this unofficial Discord and
these competitions which were
unbelievably entertaining I mean I think
this could get to a point where people
pay just to be a spectator at these
competitions I know that's a strong
statement but I mean look at Esports man
that's freaking huge
it blew my mind so I give everyone who
did that a lot of credit I was
flabbergasted it was
truly one of the one of the greater holy
[ __ ] moments I've had in the last
several years so if that is what's
happening within two weeks oh my God
holy [ __ ] and
I'm excited I'm having fun and also you
think about non-fiction and all of the
if you're a responsible non-fiction
writer
who is engaging in Creative non-fiction
but fiction I'm sorry creative
non-fiction
but within the
within the broad category of creative
you need to adhere to a certain factual
basis that is verifiable
when you remove those limiters
and you enter the world of fiction which
requires if you're going to do it well I
think some degree of consistency
and you need to ensure that story lines
mesh to some degree but when you remove
some of the common constraints of
non-fiction holy moly what I have
experienced is that you tap a Wellspring
of creativity
that is enormous that just does not
exist when you're writing fact-based
I don't want to call it literature but
when you were when you were trying to
produce fact based writing
and hmm I'm having fun man I'm having so
much fun and it opens the door to so
many things right I was talking to
somebody on my team today and I was
saying
you know
I've never ever wanted to sell
Tim Ferriss branded [ __ ] all right like
the idea of somebody walking around with
like a Tim ferrish Tim Ferriss show
T-shirt with my [ __ ] face on it like
that makes me want to puke wow I mean I
have your thong the limited edition one
needed the limited edition thong with my
face right on the balls that's true yeah
you did get the one of one that is yeah
but the first one yeah you're welcome
Happy Anniversary but the the the idea
of having my face on say a t-shirt just
always made me puke a little bit of
mouth just everyone just never want to
do it but people do that stuff right and
that's their face on a t-shirt I can see
your logo well like even just Tim
Ferriss on a shirt it feels weird to me
so it's just too dark I like I'm sure
I'm a narcissist but I'm not that
narcissistic I just couldn't get there
but the idea of having a small
subculture of people who at some point
might walk around with a [ __ ] punch logo
on their shirt
probably without [ __ ] punch on it right
that would be two in your face but like
a logo on it where anyone who sees it
knows yeah and that can be like the
fight club wink that's fun that's super
fun and I'm not saying I'm gonna do that
but it's fun for me to imagine that
being a possibility so suddenly all of
these
handcuffs that I had placed on myself
for good reasons around what I could or
couldn't do are gone they're completely
gone yeah it's called [ __ ] punch for
[ __ ] sake like I can do whatever I
want you know
it's fun it's fun I love it I'm really
excited about it I have one awkward
question for you and it just popped in
my mind as a consumer of your podcast
but something you may not agree to
divulge in which we can cut it out
but there was a point here a few minutes
ago where you said the four hour work
week is still on the New York Times
bestselling list right no I didn't say
that I said it's still one of the top
selling books okay top selling books on
Amazon so
yeah you're right because those are
different things
I'm sure there's a lot of people and Tim
don't don't take this as like I'm being
like Oh if you're willing to divulge
a lot of people would be curious what
was that yeah what was that
what did you receive for the signing
bonus to do that book because it was
your first big book oh for our work week
yeah and then what does it look like
over time and then like what do you make
now on that book like per year like can
you talk about that like yeah ego stuff
and I think it's really interesting
right I'll talk about it I'm happy to
I'm happy to talk about it
and these are not going to be well in
the case of the ongoing annual stuff I'm
not going to have an exact number but I
can give you an idea yeah yeah rough
estimates yeah yeah rough estimates so a
few things on the book publishing side
and I may have to take a pee break
because after the ketones and yeah
we're like two hours I'm having fun I'm
happy to go this is worth two hours 24
minutes in but this is this this is a
good episode we're covering a lot
my advance for the four hour work week
which is paid out in four to six
installments I want to say I don't
recall exactly over probably a year and
a half
was 75 000 okay if I remember correctly
okay
your first book you you approached them
or they approached you or had this well
the way it happened is a long story
I ended up finding a
very good editor named Stephen Hanselman
who had just become an agent He was
untested largely as an agent but I
trusted his taste and we hit it off he
then took the book and pitched it to a
bunch of editors
27 or 29
of which rejected it in some cases
rudely really rudely
ultimately sold it
on one of our last meetings in person in
New York City with editors and
Publishers
and Crown took a risk at the time crown
within random house now I think it's
Harmony books the publishing world has a
lot of shuffling constantly so it's hard
to keep track but
I believe and the person who gave the go
ahead was Steve Ross at the time I think
it was Steve Ross I think I'm getting
his first name right at then Crown so
thank you Steve
and it was 75k paid out over probably a
year or a year and a half now that's an
advance right so they're saying if you
sell that many books
you have to break that first right yeah
exactly so we're prepaying you for a
certain number of books and if you
exceed it then you get the royalty and
the royalty per copy for hardcover is
going to be anywhere between
10 and 15 what does that mean of cover
price
well a couple bucks a couple bucks right
so if it's let's just say it's 20 bucks
and let's make it it's not going to be
10 so it'll be it'd be let's call it 15
that'd be three dollars a book
from that three dollars though keep in
mind you got to pay taxes and you also
have to beforehand pay your agent which
is generally going to be 15 percent
and then anything else that comes out of
it okay you sold millions of copies I
sold millions of copies it took time it
did not flash boil as quickly as
say Atomic habits or as quickly as the
subtle art of not giving a [ __ ] it did
not flash boil as quickly as either of
those books it took some time it took
some time it came out in April of 2007
it did not hit number one New York Times
which it did first on the monthly
business list until I want to say August
it took some time the initial program
was 10 000 copies and it sold out and
then nobody could buy the book anywhere
crazy which is a which is a quality
problem but it's actually a significant
problem and
that is the advanced story or at least
the numbers on the events so what's your
yearly look like at this point like is
it like 50 Grand or well let me let me
you know I asked this recently I'm going
to try to pull up my text thread I was
trying to come up with this number
recently
so this is like a rough estimate's fine
too it doesn't have to be yeah I just
don't wanna I don't I'm very you know
how particular I I I am I don't want to
misre represent anything
but it's sub 100K is that right or more
you're probably selling over a hundred
thousand copies a year maybe maybe a
hundred to 150k okay
I mean I've written and published now
five books that were number one New York
Times and or Wall Street Journal and
many of them stuck for a very long time
you know looking at a text thread with
my agent and he sent a photo
which is pretty fun with four hour work
week
on the trending rack at Barnes and Noble
after 15 years after 15 years now on
this rack you have Think and Grow Rich
which has been around for decades yeah
you have the intelligent investor
Benjamin Grant been around for decades
of course four hour work week The
Millionaire Next Door Rich Dad Poor Dad
yeah exactly I was gonna say that one's
always up there power positive thinking
I'm just gonna name a few because why
not trust and Inspire I'm not familiar
tribal mentors so I've got two on this
rack Atomic habits Jordan Peterson 12
rules for life the 10x Rule and a number
of others so on the trending rack I'm
actually in good longevity company with
a number of these but 15 years
afterwards it's still you're like a
musical artist at this point like it's
basically like you know if you're
insert any like queen or Michael Jackson
whatever like there's just ongoing
royalties that just trickle in over time
because you're you've that's right at
that point it's it's Evergreen content
it's Evergreen by Design
and I'm looking at this here
it's amazing so I would say all of my
books
on an annual basis I mean these are not
the most successful books of all time
this is not Harry Potter but this is
probably top one percent in terms of
earnings and track record for
non-fiction books
and my total royalties pre-tax
would be in the hundreds of thousands of
dollars per year
and I don't know the exact on that that
buys a lot of Campbell Soup and getting
more abuse too it buys a lot of Campbell
Soup but but let's just take it as an
example I mean I have put
many hundreds of thousands of dollars
into the development of [ __ ] punch and I
want more people of all the specifics
but there's there's a lot of money that
has gone into college that's where you
went with that that's amazing yeah so no
this is just to say you're like I've
taken all of your money from four hour
work week and put it right back into
[ __ ] punch so you [ __ ] no well
it's not so much a guilt trip it's just
to say
I think it's
it's crazy to think about the fact that
I could take almost all or all of my
royalties for all of my books for a
couple decades of Decades of work
all of the proceeds that I get from that
I put into an nft project which doesn't
highlight that an nft project done well
costs a lot of money although I do think
it requires some it's to highlight the
fact that part of my reason for engaging
with web 3 and nfts was the promise that
artists could
resurrect in a sense their creative
powers
through an ongoing royalty which turns
out
this is a shocker and was a shocker to a
lot of people is not automatically baked
in and guaranteed buy your smart
contract across all platforms right it's
platform dependent let's be real let me
give you some real talk now Tim like
this is really good okay real talk is
that you've had 5 396 each in total
volume yeah your creator fee is 6.9 yeah
so you did and and I'm not please please
like let everyone know on this podcast
what you did it no one does which is the
primary sale you gave all the money to
charity the secondary sale you're saying
this is what's going to maintain the
project which I think is
I actually said Tim might use it on
Whiskey and Horrors I said right like I
I didn't even address with secondary
sales given the Tim is single again the
the the second second piece of that may
may kick him so oh boy we can cut that
out so
Jesus I'm sorry Tim I didn't mean it's
all right all right so so so 5 396 total
e times .069 your creator fee is 372
each so 372 obviously times like let's
just say so 5 396 total e times .069
your creator fee is 372 each so 372
obviously times like let's just say eth
is at 1200 that's means you've already
broken even you've you're 446 000 in
secondary sales have not even recouped
my costs for [ __ ] punch yet but yes
costs for more than a half million yes
wow it's crazy well and you have to pay
taxes on this because this is this is
revenue right so and that is not
counting my time I'm working at below
minimum wage given the number of hours I
put into this but if we discount that if
we're just considering hours for
contractors the
the costs which I view as an investment
for artists for my team members who are
allocating a significant portion of
let's just say their annual salary to
these things
I do not think I have yet broken even
and I figuratively fine with it I'm
totally fine with it you're gonna break
even dude
there's no doubt I'm not worried yeah
I'm not worried I don't know as the
storyline matures the lore matures your
commitment matures like it there's no
doubt that dude
well I won't even say what other
projects they can compare these against
but like you you are you're so much more
yeah the Project's doing well the
Project's doing well and
and what's most exciting to me is the
trend that I am seeing and the
coalescing of
a community of people who are actually
excited about it and thoughtfully
excited about they're not just drunk on
[ __ ] punch fumes they're actually
thinking about the Laura they're
tracking the Laura they're tracking some
of the details that a lot of folks have
missed yeah and they're paying attention
and they're excited about it they're
having fun with it which is the whole
[ __ ] point this is this is exactly
what I'm most excited about the moon
Birds community and what we're doing
over there is that we're finally getting
the point where I feel like the
community is is tipped over and said
we're in this for the long term they're
excited about what we're building they
excited about some of the novel
mechanics that we're doing on the
technical side that haven't been done
before or being done in different ways
and it once you get there you're in a
great place the project because you you
feel good you feel energized to go into
work and like really put in more energy
into this you know which is what we can
all kind of hope for so
I will say a couple little things to hit
before we wrap things up one thing
certainly worth checking out for
everyone out there especially high-risk
folks and Tim I I purposely put this in
the rundown so that we could chat about
it but there is a mode
new to iOS called Apple lockdown mode
and if you go into settings on your
iPhone
you'll probably do this because I know
you're paranoiding like this [ __ ] but
like if you you enable lockdown mode it
actually disables like five very common
things that you would typically allow on
the iPhone but it prevents
most of the the the compromises that
happen from like State actors like like
other governments and like sophisticated
attackers yeah it locks it all down yeah
I'm looking at this exactly protect
devices against extremely rare and
highly sophisticated cyber attacks like
a lot of payloads meaning like the the
vulnerabilities will come over SMS right
or or text message and if you get
something from say someone that you
don't know yeah by default blocks them
like things like just obvious things you
should have enabled it does [ __ ] a
few things in terms of the functionality
of the iPhone anything else before we
wrap things up well I'm kind of curious
you have a couple of bullets
love your your spelling am I done with
Ayahuasca I'm sure I'm assuming that is
the question and then that's right and
then about investing let's talk about
those two so Rook on the Alaska front
let me just preface this a bit in that I
would consider you to be the first
person I ever heard about Ayahuasca like
let's call it like eight years ago or
whatever the [ __ ] it was like a long
time ago it was from you yeah and nobody
was doing that [ __ ] it was like you had
to get a proper Shaman blah blah now
like Los Angeles like you know CVS is
doing like I lost the things at night
like like it's like everywhere yeah
what God what's hey you you [ __ ]
everyone and that you created this crazy
Trend and and and have you found durable
lasting effects from it like would you
still recommend it
for most people or what what's your take
I wouldn't recommend it for most people
I have found durable
benefits and I've also found
unpredictable risks so I I I will say
that about a year and a half ago maybe
two years ago I had
an extended deep depressive episode for
several months precipitated by two
nights of consuming Ayahuasca and
there are reasons for that it's not
unexplainable it was related to a lot of
the content of that experience in a
certain
sense of meaninglessness
and nihilism that was I think a
predictable result of the
content and experience that I went
through and
I think in some way the conclusion
Landing in this void of meaninglessness
and nihilism is Justified but that
doesn't make it productive and it was
certainly not psychologically beneficial
so
after that experience
I decided to take a Hiatus from
partaking and there there are
significant not just psychological but
in some cases physiological risks
associated with Ayahuasca you can you
can experience especially if you're on
concurrent medications like certain
ssris serotonin syndrome you can have
severe severe side effects so this is
not a trivial
undertaking and
I have largely in the last
year year and a half
paste down significantly
any consumption of psychedelics it's I I
don't I think that they will be an
ongoing component of my life
until
it's game over or at least this game
over
and I transition from this physical form
should we say I I do think that they
will be in the [ __ ] punch that you truly
are that's right until we all Ascend to
the Valhalla of [ __ ] punch but
I do anticipate it'll be an ongoing
aspect and
important
ritual component in my life
but I have dialed back the frequency
substantially let me ask you a question
yeah did you see the benefits degrade
over time in meaning that like
if
if you had to go back and talk to your
your your first Ayahuasca self yeah like
let's call it like eight years ago or
whatever it was 10 plus years ago now
yeah yeah let's say 10 plus years ago
would you say hey Tim do it 10 times or
do it five times or do it whatever like
is there is there a kind of beneficial
return the more that you do it or
I think it depends a lot on the
individual it also depends on the
reasons for which you are using it I
would say I wouldn't have said that to
myself
I wouldn't have said do it 10 times and
call it quits I wouldn't have said that
I would have said here's what I probably
would have said I would have said
number one
if you take this seriously the deeper
you go the more interesting it becomes
if you
pursue very qualified training
through people who have a proven lineage
of focusing on this for hundreds of
years
you can go very very deep and it will
get more interesting
I would have simultaneously said
be very cautious about how deep you go
because you can get lost if this is not
your tradition if this is not your
culture
if you've not been steeped in this if
you didn't start drinking Ayahuasca when
you were five years old which is when a
lot of
these
let's just call them professionals we'll
start drinking is when they're five six
or seven years old like a full dose or
like just little tasters I don't know
how it's introduced probably at smaller
doses but very quickly getting to full
doses very very quickly getting to full
doses is it fun when you do a little
little cough syrup like on the side or
do you have to do a full dose to get the
one thing if you decide to do it again
this year yeah
if you would have me yeah I would do it
with you okay for like 10 years all
right that's interesting
that's interesting
all right I will not hold you to that
but that's good to know yeah I'd love to
man I I know that you would be a good
guy to know you'd be a good friend and I
know you'd be a good shoulder and you
know I know there's having that high
high-dose mushrooms
I cried and wept over my Dad's passing
over a lot of [ __ ] that would obviously
comes up and you need you need to
support structure and I know you would
be a fantastic friend oh thanks I would
I would love that if you'd yeah yeah
thanks Kevin and also the meditation
Trend you've been doing will be
instrumental it will be incredibly
incredibly helpful
so that's good to know and and I will
say that you know I'll I'll just wrap up
quickly the the advice I would have
given to my younger selves number one is
the deeper you go the more interesting
it will become
assuming that you have proper guidance
from people who have a proven track
record
before this was fashionable of over
Generations cultivating and awareness
and toolkit for interacting with these
spaces
he said you know that's yeah I was just
gonna say one little little tidbit to
that you know even just being out here a
couple months I hear hey come to our
Ayahuasca little thing in the LA Hills
blah blah and it seems very commercial
at this point yeah and I'm like in my
head I was always like I'm only gonna
trust him on this [ __ ] because he's got
the OG the original [ __ ] the good stuff
the good you know I'm very strict you
know I'm strict yeah and I'm very we
only seek out the best yep and I'm very
very very very particular and meticulous
about how I assess expertise I think
that is one of my one of my core
forms of expertise is assessing
expertise I think I'm very good at it
and I agree I I think the vast majority
of people who consume these things are
children playing with loaded
handguns they don't realize the risks
they're taking
and the horrifying episodes generally
don't get a lot of air time
so there's a survivorship bias where
people end up hearing the the positive
life-altering experiences and then the
incorrect conclusion is made
that
the vast majority of experiences are
like that and I have not seen any
evidence to suggest that's true there
are many positive life-altering
experiences but
Ayahuasca specifically is a big gun it
is very powerful and
the other
warning I would give in addition to if
you go deep
given that you are not native to this
environment there is a risk that you
will become lost
and being lost can be
in indescribably terrifying experience
where the line between
reality and what you might perceive as a
hyper reality in this other dimension or
fabricated
reality as a UI as we perceive it versus
any type of objective truth things can
get very very unclear very quickly and I
don't expect anyone to understand this
or even
take it as reasonable that you could
have that experience if you haven't been
there but take my word for it you can
get to some very very slippery Terrain
furthermore I would say no matter how
many times you have done this
doesn't matter if it's 10 or 100 or 200
you'd always stand
the chance of pulling a joker card from
the deck and getting your [ __ ] ass
handed to you in a very serious in a
very serious way yeah I don't want to do
it anymore
that has lasting consequences now I will
say just for you Kevin don't like to fly
either
the group matters and I will say more so
than perhaps at least from a format a
traditional format perspective the
people in the group matter so you are
going to have
this is another reason or another
example of where I think many people
don't are you sane though when you're
doing this like if I look over at you
yeah
while we're doing this you're not going
to be like
doing something crazy but my tip's
freaking out [ __ ] I'm freaking out he's
masturbating in the corner generally not
no yeah generally I'm okay generally I'm
not like you would be Solid Ground well
I'm not like the Exorcist right my
head's not like spinning around while
I'm vomiting in all directions and
speaking in tongues things can get very
strange and they almost certainly will
get very strange but it is I have never
had the experience actually I take that
back my for in my first few experiences
there were one or two times where I felt
out of control fully out of control
and was completely dislocated from
anything resembling this reality but the
generally speaking now
or in recent history
I can go through very very very
challenging experiences but if someone
near me says Tim are you okay or Tim how
are you doing
I can reply to that in perfectly
coherent English
even if I even if even if I am
by all subjective interpretations
completely removed from time space
identity I can I can still respond to
that which is a developed I think that's
a cultivated skill at least for me
but the fact of the matter remains that
I could not have foreseen how
violently
I would be destabilized from that
experience
a year and a half two years ago and I
think that was in part due to a degree
of overconfidence after many rounds for
a non-clinician for a non-professional I
mean the professionals drank four or
five nights a week and do so for years
and years and years on end so anyone
who's like I've done Ayahuasca 10 times
I understand Ayahuasca you are
setting yourself up for like spiritual
head kick the reason I'm excited about
this and tell me if if this is it if
this is foolish and and I'm fine with
you saying that
the one thing that I I really appreciate
about
this practice of meditation is that
there's two things one it's it's Henry
slaps his legs and he says just this
just this this is this is the moment
just this and like that really snaps me
back into like this this is the moment
and the second piece is that this idea
of surrender yeah where you have
something that's facing you and you're
like that's just a thought let's
surrender back to the moment is a bit of
a big piece of this practice
and do you think that either of those
things would be helpful 100 yes or is
that I'll tell you how they'll be
helpful in my experience and how they'll
be a hindrance or how they can be
hindrance so
on the helpful side
in these very
let's call them unusual
and Alternate experiences of reality in
say an Ayahuasca experience and you can
have nothing nice also by the way you
get a brew that's super weak or are you
just simply for whatever reason have
your body veto the experience you can
have
null experiences it's pretty wild
I have had those they're rare but I've
had experiences where I've had three
cups which I never do three drinks and
I've been more sober than I am right now
because I had one real drink better two
real drinks
and I don't have a good explanation for
how that happens but
let's just assume we're talking about
the full ride and you're in
there's an expression
and this is used in therapy but it's
especially applicable I think to some of
these stronger psychedelic experiences
which is what you resist persists
so if you're having an emotion
it's not it's not that the emotion is
the problem it's your response to the
emotion that's the problem right right
so that is very much I think
compatible
spanning the gap between what we might
consider meditation and a psychedelic
experience it's the same it's just
magnified
if you resist something in meditation
there's a certain consequence if you
resist something in psychedelics it's
that consequence times a hundred so if
you're able to rehearse and practice and
cultivate the ability to observe without
resisting it is very helpful
the risk and I have seen this with
experienced meditators is that they
effectively in the Psychedelic
experience are able to
almost dissociate from a first-person
experience and sit on the sidelines they
don't allow themselves to be taken yeah
I love that that's what I want to do
[Laughter]
and there's a certain wisdom in that
there's a safety in that but you do not
in my in my opinion you don't get the
full experience you're the coach you're
watching the players on the field and
you're like yeah good job keep it up yep
yeah exactly yeah
but you're not you're not having the in
the zone experience I get it of being on
the playing field in a way that allows
you to Ride the Lightning well that's
not true surrender then right because
you would surrender if you're really
truly surrendering you would you would
let it take you if you allow it it's a
it's for meditators it's a conscious
decision in many cases unless they just
unless they just have the choice most
people don't most people don't they just
they don't for most people it's not
surrendering it's being taken without
thought of there being an alternative
right
right for meditators for meditators
I will say I mean there there is a dose
that will render
oh sure you
just a piece of [ __ ] it could just be
one cup depending on the Brew it could
just make you a piece of Driftwood in a
hundred foot wave right I mean there is
there is there there are circumstances
in which I don't really care how good
you are at meditating scare me stop
talking about it
but but the room composition matters and
this is where I'm gonna get out there so
welcome to Crazy Town everybody but
when you
have proper guidance in the form of
someone who is quarterbacking the
experience and you have a room
of let's just say
four to eight people I think around six
is really the sweet spot for me that is
the right size team for something like
this
you are going to effectively have
unprotected spiritual sex with everybody
in that room which is part of the reason
why I typically do not drink with any
strangers I want to know what is under
the hood for people on some level
because it all gets put on the same
shared table in that experience
and
I don't have any scientific proof for
this I only have my own
direct experience and
I try to trust in the Fidelity of my
direct experience stuff gets shared in
that room so it's good to have some
basic familiarity of what you're what
you're contending with
and
well what's interesting you don't it
doesn't necessarily manifest in a
negative way so for instance
I have a friend who I have sat with many
dozens of times now and
we will often have the exact same
experience we will see the same things
we will hear the same things we will
experience nausea at exactly the same
times or more interestingly
what if it will get super nauseous and
then the nausea will disappear and then
the other person will vomit as if that
has been handed off to the other person
they assume that burden or
responsibility or feeling and they
process it for the other person it's
very odd it's very odd and it is very
very common so
we should get a good crew together who
are we gonna get it's you me David
Blaine
Mike Mike Shinoda lead singer a kiss
I gotta run I gotta get back to my girls
okay this has been awesome yeah good to
hang man great to see you man
I want to say a couple things real quick
before we wrap up one
Happy New Year I love you I miss you
yeah I love you too brother it's always
great to do these it's been so many fun
years of us doing these these ridiculous
makes me so happy ridiculous podcasts
yeah you know like speaking of [ __ ]
punch like this is the [ __ ] bunch of
podcasts yeah it really is it's just us
being ridiculous like it's hashtag front
forward slouch
yeah the thing I I love about like just
to say this because this goes on your
main feed is like you know you have a
very successful podcast that makes a lot
of money doing what you do so well and
the fact that you would say hey I'm
gonna dumb it down from time to time and
just have a good time and do these types
of shows like it it it means a lot man
it's like it's it's it's kind of
I think it's the core of who we are
though yeah we we both like to be
professionals on some level and then
also just [ __ ] it we're gonna die soon
let's have a good time yeah so 100 man I
I love these conversations I miss you
miss the family and I I hope to spend
more time in person so I'll at the very
least you come to La more often you're
thinking about that right I would like
to spend some more time out there
perfect weather there's a lot to be said
for it easy access to Nature I get to I
said
a lot I'm just in terms of the dating
life yeah yeah
it's true it's a large playing field out
there and uh
a lot of pickleball a lot of pickleball
I don't even know what that means oh
yeah yeah you don't know what it means
what a Class Act and
I also have a lot of friends out there I
also have a lot of friends and it'll be
fun to do these in person man we used to
do in person all the time we used to
always do in person yeah it was so fun
so we looked a lot a lot younger less
Grace ball sacks yeah the ball sacks for
for really
responded in their youthful vigor I had
like a a ponytail on mine I have little
little little ponytails it was good luck
on that note oh my God I'm sorry if we
offend anyone today I'm not sorry
if you're offended please Jesus relax
and subscribe you're gonna do you
unsubscribe you're gonna die soon have
some fun
all right man good all right brother
good to see you man and to everybody
listening I don't even know if we're
gonna have show notes but maybe
[Laughter]
Jim dot blog slash podcast that's where
you can find the more serious stuff and
happy holidays and happy New Years
everybody Happy New Year to you too man
all right brother take care take care
buddy